Dr
e
okay
la
I
than
youate
be
[Music]
seats
please
e
[Music]
an
excuse
the house will come to order the chair
recognizes a member from Auburn
representative Osborne who moves the
house adourn the session of March 7th
2024 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the eyes have it in the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by guest chaplain Hillsboro fire
department chaplain Pastor Paul O'Neal
Church
let us
pray heavenly father as we gathered in
this hallowed
chamber we recognize you as the Unseen
Sovereign of Our
Lives May you guide all of our
Representatives this day as they make
decisions that will make our lives
better we would humbly ask that you give
all our Representatives the physical
strength to conduct the people's
business
be with their families who support them
for those Representatives who face
medical challenges we would ask your
healing
touch for those who struggle with
personal or private
issues may you come to their aid and for
those who face difficult situations
grant them
wisdom thank you Lord for each elected
official and each staff person in the
sacrifices they make bless them in this
great state that we live in and finally
for the for all those excellent First
Responders both police and fire who
serve in our cities and towns keep them
safe this day in your holy name we pray
amen
amen jerck and I as a member of marac
Representative ncy Murphy who will lead
us in Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to
the stands
na
indivisible andice for
all chair now recognizes Trey Grant a
student at marac high school who will
anth
[Music]
the
I
[Music]
w
[Applause]
think
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness Representatives Ellison Linda
gold James Murphy clamon Summers tensar
and treven the day important business
Representatives Hicks O'Hara and Traer
the day illness in the family
sandborn these leades of ation shall be
house the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Jacob nen and terara Sophia
students from Bedford High School our
Pages for the
[Applause]
day
Mr Speaker please welcome Kristen Grant
mother of the anthem performer guest of
Representative Nancy Murphy Kyla Hubble
guest of Representative yella dick and
Chrissy nordgren and sarin South Hall
guests of Representatives walner and
hacken Phillips and fourth grade
students from the Iber holes go Middle
High School guests of Representatives
Pratt Drago and Tim haill they are with
us in the gallery
house
[Applause]
clerk thank you Mr Speaker ladies and
gentlemen you'll never see me here at
this Podium
again that being said uh the the gcts
team uh was in here for several hours
ear earlier this week to work on the
microphones and I have some mic
etiquette that they've asked me to share
with
you uh and please if there if if your
friends aren't in the room tell them
later please make sure that the mic is
about 3 to 5 Ines away about a fist
length and about an inch below your
mouth if you're too close to the mic you
may hear Distortion and popping and that
will be overpowered by your
voice especially on plosive sounds if
you hear
Distortion back
[Music]
up try not to turn your head too far
away Mr Speaker as you're talking to
your colleagues in the chamber please
keep the mic close to
you don't talk too far away from the mic
Mr
Speaker those are just a few points that
are are folks uh uh have asked to pass
along for your edification for speaking
at the well and and this is for your
benefit in the chamber as well because
we have people that um it's the sound in
here is not like it used to be people
to so please be mindful and respectful
of your colleagues uh when you're doing
[Music]
you the house will now attend to
Memorial remarks for the representative
from Hanover The Honorable Sharon
norgren the chair recognizes
representative
walner
thank you Mr
Speaker can't believe I'm the first
person who has to do these
mics okay can you hear me
okay if you ever attended a meeting with
representative Sharon norren this may
sound familiar to you do we have an
agenda we have to start start with an
agenda representative norgren always had
an agenda whether it was for a shared
Ride To Conquer a weekly meeting on her
porch with local Democrats or a house
finance division 3 meeting Sharon who
passed away on February 10th had an
agenda serving her Town her State her
party and her country she was a quiet
but for formidable presence in this hall
for the past 36
years representative norran was a native
of Minnesota by birth but became a proud
Granite stator by choice she met the
love of her life dick norgren in
Minnesota while he was visiting during
an academic break they fell in love got
married and moved to New
Hampshire when Dick start when Dick
started work at Mary Hill Hitchcock
hospital in Handover in the
1970s the norns enjoyed witnessing all
of their children's Sports competitions
their school activities and watching
them flourish and growing into wonderful
people later in life representative
norren loved to travel with her family
they took many trips together including
Costa Rica and England representative
norran was a proud spouse and mother to
Physicians proud mother to an
es equestrian thank you and a proud
grandmother to three wonderful
grandchildren at the time of her death
representative noram was serving her
18th term in the New Hampshire house
representing Hanover and lme previously
representative noran served on the
Hanover select board for nine years six
as a first as the first woman chair
Sharon served many years in house
leadership six years as the deputy
Democratic leader three terms as a
member of the children and family law
committee and 13 terms on the finance
committee where she served as chair of
division three and vice chair of the
committee her colleagues in the house
and Beyond looked to Sharon as an expert
on New Hampshire Health and Human
Service policy and appreciated her
unyielded building priority that she
placed on the welfare of Children and
Families representative noran was the
Prime sponsor of legislation creating
the council for children and adolescents
with chronic health
issues and New Hampshire children's
trust fund which was established to
fight child abuse and neglect she later
became the chair of that fund's
governing
board representative norgren
participated and negotiated ated 13
budget Cycles often as chair of division
three we know representative noran's
service did not stop at the State House
Sharon served as a delegate to the
Democratic National Convention
participated in New Hampshire's first in
the nation primaries for decades hosting
nationally known candidates and
Statewide political
fundraisers Sharon was a model mentor
always ready with witty words of wisdom
or inspiration from her long record of
service if you ever had a personal issue
or conflict to resolve representative
norgren knew how to
troubleshoot Sharon always had
advice sometimes invited and sometimes
unsolicited and when the conversation
was over representative norgren's famous
departing tagline was keep in touch tou
which
exemplified the fact she was an expert
at making connections and building
Community representative norgren's years
of hard work and dedication to public
service was recognized this past
September when a celebration in honor of
her 80th birthday at the farm of
honorable Peter Burling in Cornish the
attendees which included sitting members
of Congress and the who's who of the
past and present Democratic leaders
colleagues past and present from the
legislature and many friends and
families exemplifies just how genuine
and widespread the love and appreciation
for her service
was at the birthday celebration a long a
lifelong Handover Republican shared kind
words about serving as a select board
colleague with representative norren
more than 40 years ago he prayed raised
her work as the first woman to chair the
select board in Anover and he recalled
fondly the way they dis disagreed with
with calm and reasoned arguments with
deep respect and even with affection he
praised Sharon's ability to convert
disagreement into judicious compromise
and he insisted that the crowd gathered
pay attention that all she had
accomplished Sharon knew how to get
things done and how to make politics
work the celebration of her 80th
birthday was meaningful because those
gathered had a chance to thank her for
her de dedic Decades of service and
friendship and weren't we the lucky ones
to have told her all that she met to us
before she passed in memory of
Representative norgren a flag was flown
over the state house on February 13th
the flag has been given to Sher
family representative norgren is
survived by her husband dick who cared
for her unfailingly during her recent
illness and who was at her side when she
died she is survived by her son Rob his
wife Julia and their children Andrew and
Benjamin and Sharon's daughter Chrissy
her husband John and their son
saurin Sharon is remembered as a
dedicated public servant loving mother
grandmother and wife and a fierce
friend today we recognize our privilege
to witness her final acts of service and
we are resolved to carry her work
forward Sharon will be deeply missed by
by all who loved her and worked with
her please join me in um standing for a
silence
I'd like to make sure we all extend a
real nice welcome to Sharon's family
gallery
[Applause]
for what reason am member rise move to
place the memorial remarks in the
objection the house will now attend to
consent calendar Mr Speaker there are no
calendar are there any other bills to be
removed representative wosman moves at
the consent calendar will the relevant
amendments and printed in the house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it consent
calendar is adopted house will now
calendar
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which has
referred House Bill 1204 an act relative
to government agent in entries into
secured premises consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation the bill ought
to pass with Amendment s of Terry Roy
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to
legisl sen of Ray Newman for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is
0839 H printed in house record 10 page
44 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes representative
Newman
chairman my apologies Mr speaker thank
Speaker
first a little background about this
bill currently state law allows entry
for the parts of property outside the
immediate area of a home
itself the idea behind this longstanding
allowance is called the Open Fields
Doctrine which says there is no
expectation of privacy in an open field
this exception has been in the law for
years the minority feels that there is
practice no single property owner
testified about a need for this
bill we heard testimony from the chief
of police of the town of Ry who told us
that whenever officers see a sign for no
trespassing on the
property they have reason to enter there
is they allain to always get a
warrant they are also taught that the
New Hampshire Supreme Court has gone so
far as to say if there is time to get a
warrant it is the only safe way to
proceed he said this bill is not needed
and the minority
agrees the bottom line is this bill is a
problem it is important to
note that
in the public hearing we heard one thing
but the P but the bill says something
that is
different the testimony indicated that
land subject to open to the Open Fields
Doctrine now needs the consent of of a
warrant but only if it is for secured
property which means land posted with no
trespassing
signs one section of that of the build
requirement however the bill goes well
beyond that
point the next two sections of the bill
require that consent must be gained or a
warrant must be shown to the owner of
private land now private land is not
bill nothing in the bill requires
government agents to get consent for a
warrant or for a non-private land and
this bill just as aide only applies to
government agent it's it does not apply
to ordinary citizens this only applies
agents the next two sections of the bill
so it so it now requires for private
land that you get a a warrant warrant or
consent this completely rejects the open
field doctrine that I mentioned and
expands the reach of this bill to 3.3
million acres of non-post
land which is 91% of the land in New
Hampshire this is a massive change that
needs further
discussion also the definition of
government agent in this bill requires
that any local estate official who is
employed are contracted by the
bill we need to change that definition
so that it only affects Lo inprivate
land like the need to enforce
laws about off-highway recreational
vehicles that need need to be enforced
the bottom line is that the this bill
needs more far more scrutiny than it is
received to date so please press the red
button to deete the otpa so another
motion can be made and Mr Speaker I
vote a division vote has been requested
we're down to the last speaker if
members will start migrating to their
seats it will Quicken the process chair
recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
this bill doesn't need any more study um
we've been studying it for 200 and
something years it's the
Constitution we do not want government
agents I don't care what their job title
is to be able to traes through our
property without a warrant if you have
uh three acres of land they're not
allowed to go within the small circle
around your house that's called the
curtilage otherwise they're free to
wander wherever they want and do
whatever they want in your property this
bill says if you put up a no trespassing
sign police that means you too get a
warrant thank
you
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended majority on
hb24 this is a division vote members
take your seats a roll call has been
requested is that sufficiently seconded
this sufficiently seconded this will be
Vote
Yes
reason
e
the motion before us is a majority
amended this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Harriet goth
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the bill attempts
to solve a problem that doesn't exist
and that no uh property owner showed up
in favor of it and if I know the Bill
runs counter to a long-standing US
Supreme Court ruling that affirmed that
a citizen has no expectation of privacy
in their property outside the immediate
area of their home a ruling known as the
Open Fields Doctrine and finally if I
know that the drafter of the bill is an
outof State lobbyist and has no rights
or authority in New Hampshire I would
press the red button to defeat the art
to pass motion thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognized represent janen for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that as an elected constable and a PL
board member I initially
had uh concerns on this bill but I also
know that a notwithstanding Clause was
added so all activities currently
authorized by Statute can continue
including
ohrv enforcement planning board
inspection building inspection fire
inspection labor inspection fishing law
inspection hunting inspection Etc would
button the mo Bish the majority
committee report of aut passes amended
onh House Bill 1204 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations
seconds make sure all your machines are
turned
on
[Music]
while members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 228 voting a 139 voting a the
Joo the committee on criminal justice
Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 1276 FN act relative to
repealing a Prohibition on the
possession or sale of blackjacks slug
shots and metallic Knuckles except by or
two minors having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
the bill ought to pass pres of Dennis
Manion for the majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unble agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen David muse from the
minority of the committee chair recogniz
h
thank you Mr
Speaker with this bill would do is end
our state's current prohibition on
people 18 and over from carrying or
possessing with intent to sell street
fighting weapons these weapons include
blackjacks breast Knuckles and something
called a slungshot the prohibition under
the bill would continue for miners under
the age of
18 currently carrying or possessing
these weapons is a misdemeanor in the
state of New Hampshire the injuries
these weapons cause can be
devastating in addition to inflicting
concussions and brain damage they can
fracture skulls break bones destroy
teeth and cause wounds that require
dozens of stitches and plastic surgery
to fix if they can be fixed at
all unlike previous public hearings
where these weapons were framed as
Antiquated weapons that belong in Museum
this time we didn't hear the Antiques
Road Show argument instead we heard that
the weapons of choice for street gangs
and lone sharks are actually weapons now
for
self-defense well as hard as I tried and
as long as I searched online one of the
things that I couldn't find as a single
example of these weapons actually being
used for
self-defense but when I looked for brass
knuckle attacks and assaults and
searched on terms like that I got back
1, 160,000
results the bottom line is if we if we
remove this
prohibition um we'll be doing a lot more
than making these weapons available to
average
citizens we're also going to be making
them available to some of our below
average citizens who are criminals and
Thugs who can and will use them for what
they have always been used for to to
intimidate to coerce and to assault
their
victims as for the fact that this bill
retains the prohibition for people under
the age of 18 this adds no more
protection for kids in our schools
because many New Hampshire High Schools
including those in some of our largest
cities have students who are over the
age of
18 something else to consider is that if
this bill should somehow become law it
would create a situation where we'd be
prosecuting children for something that
is legal for adults to
do at a time when we are visually
struggling to come up with ways we can
agree on that enhance the safety of our
communities the one thing we absolutely
should not be doing is something that
would instantly make our communities our
schools our bars and our public
gathering places any less safe by
rejecting this unneeded bill all of us
have a genuine opportunity to to do
something very meaningful to protect our
constituents against a real threat a
threat that if you wave this bill
through you will officially
own please join me in pressing the red
button to defeat the ought to pass
motion so another motion can be made and
Mr Speaker I request a roll call vote
Manion
thank you Mr
Speaker I support the autop pass motion
on House Bill
1276 blackjacks slung shots and brass
knuckles the fact that most of us do not
know what two of these items are tells
you how old this ban is today these
tools have become more of a novelty an
ornament some would hang from the
rearview mirror next to the air
freshener or the covid mask we heard in
Committee in from the previous speaker
about how dangerous these Antiquated
tools
are you heard once we make these legal
somehow there's going to be a mad rush
on your local slungshot store and
18-year-old high school students are
going to snatch up every one of these
things and bring them to school if that
were the case why not we currently have
a problem with 18-year-olds bringing
knives billy clubs throwing stars and
nunchucks to
school because it's still prohibited on
school
grounds we also heard in committee how
these tools have been used to inflict
devast devastating injuries to include
orbital socket
fractures if my wife or daughter were
walking in my neighborhood or jogging on
our local rail trail it would not
concern me if they inflicted an orbital
socket fracture on an as salent looking
to sexually sexually assault harm or
kill them just a few weeks ago a local
TV station ran a news story in response
to the murder of lake and Riley it was
titled runers urged to be aware of
surroundings carry self-defense tools
self defense tools just because
something could be used as an offensive
weapon doesn't mean it should be banned
as a defensive option it is important to
note that these illegal tools are not
banned for law enforcement officers or
hunters in my 30 years in law
enforcement I have not possessed no I do
I know of any other officer who has
possessed any of these tools and while
I'm not a hunter I've had many
interactions with hunters in my career
and when I see a deer in the back of
their pickup truck or strapped to the
hood of their bu Road Master not one
deer not one had an orbital socket
fracture what is this tell us police
officers and Hunters do not carry these
things because they have
firearms do you know who not who might
not have a firearm a female jogger guns
are heavy expensive intimidating and
require ongoing training and practice
but a lightweight discreet pair of brass
knuckles that's a perfect defensive tool
for a jogger a tool that would be
readily available a tool that would be
natural to effectively use and a tool
that can level the playing field and an
attack I would go so far as to call
these harm reduction tools for these
reasons I urge you to support the a pass
motion and pass this Common Sense
legislation by pressing the green button
thank
you s Harry goth has requested a roll
seconded it is sufficient seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 1276 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the primary purpose of Street
Fighting weapons is street fighting and
if I also know that the chiefs of Police
Association signed in opposing this bill
uh when we conducted the public hearing
then would I ask you to press the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you chair recognize representative
rhs for a parliament
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that no New Hampshire citizen
is below average and by leging these
does not mean that a person can use them
unlawfully and if I know that a person
that is in possession of a hunting
license is already allowed to own these
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that a
student regardless of how old they are
is not allowed to possess any weapon
while on school grounds would I now
press screen with the committee thank
you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 1276 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposer press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent all members president had the
opportunity to vote El will attend to
198 voting a 175 voting a the committee
adopted Committee on Public criminal
justice and Public Safety to which is
referred House Bill 1336 relative to
employees firearms and locked Vehicles
this comes without recommendation for
what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I Rise to make a motion
State your motion I move that we lay
House Bill 1336 upon the
table the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1336 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those oppos nay no guys haven't and
table majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1108 an act relative to
establishing a committee to study the
role of colleges universities
contributing to the student loan crisis
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative M Meyer for the majority
of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
you know Mike beler for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
representative
morning the student loan issue is in
fact fact a real crisis for us not just
for those indebted but for all of us in
the state and in this country delayed
marriages and home
purchases delayed families lessened
entrepreneurship less Innovation and
birth rates below replacement level
these are
civilizational
threats but so often we hear suggested
that the only solution is to rob the
innocent party the
taxpayer the taxpayer didn't Lobby
government to back student loans the
taxpayer didn't raise tuition to cover
expanded administrative roles and
multiply the corrosive critical theory
based departments driving the American
cultural
revolution colleges and universities did
that we should take a hard
look at their culpability for this debt
crisis and consider
legislation to fix it and this bill
would establish a committee to look at
that I'd ask you to consider voting
green thank you J recognizes
representative
Miler uh thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues I rise today to urge
Ur you to support the itl bipartisan
motion on HB
1108 the issue of student debt is well
known and recognized by the usnh and
Community College system
leaders HB
1108 is not needed we heard testimony
from the higher education leaders on
method methods that they have been using
to marginalize institutional
expenses both systems have United to
coordinate purchasing practices they've
Consolidated course options to reduce
duplication of course offerings and
reduce course
multiplicity leaders of these
institutions meet on a regular basis to
moderate institutional
expenses further there is an agreement
within the two systems to provide
automatic student matriculation from
community colleges to the UNH system
this allows students to complete their
first two years at a community college
at a reduced cost thus saving of cost
expenses to families the bipartison
support of this bill recognized in HB
1108 is not needed due to the focused
approach of our higher education
institutional leaders to contain cost
please support the bipartisan itl motion
thank you Mr Speaker and I request a
division
vote division vote a division vote has
seats
e
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 118 this is a
division vote chair recognizes the
representative Belia for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that I aired perhaps having corn beef
and cabbage on the mind and would
instead now ask the body to vote red
that another motion can be
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that New Hampshire's University and Co
Community College systems are very aware
of student loan debt crisis and if I
know that they meet regularly to
determine ways to reduce costs such as
coordinating purch interesting practices
as well as allowing automatic student
matriculation from a community college
to a university and finally if I know
that establishing a committee to study
the role of colleges and universities in
contributing to the student loan crisis
is completely unnecessary as it is
already being studied when I now press
the green button thank you the motion
before is a majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislator and House Bill
1108 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
that all members president had the
opportunity to vote alsoo attend to
vote 233 voting a 143 voting a the
adopted
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1162 relative to
teaching discrimination public schools
and discrimination in public workplaces
comes Rec recommendation representative
cascaden moves ought to pass the chair
leas prior to the anti-discrimination
law that this bill tries to
repeal many of us including people in
this room right now have had our kids
and our friends kids come home upset
because they were being taught that all
white people are racist and that because
they were a boy they were
oppressors um since this law was passed
I haven't heard any of that so I would
say it seems to be working and there's
no reason to repeal
it but schools businesses have started
discriminatory they started a new
Campaign which is more subtle but just
as pernicious and I'd like to read a
letter that our committee got from a
person of color on what is currently
being pushed which is racist and
discriminatory I would like to address
the committee on the inclusion of
diversity equity and inclusion policies
within our state being a person of color
it is my experience that Dei should
instead be labeled division exclusion
and
indoctrination instead of judging people
by their character as Martin Luther King
aspired to these policies aim at disc
discriminating against races that happen
to be out of favor at this time
just as we look back on History right
now and bow our heads in shame at how
blacks were once treated today's
generation seems bent on creating
another Injustice that it will have to
repent of in future Generations by
choosing favored skin colors and
endowing certain levels of melatonin
with rights that are denied
others the efforts of Dei policies to
help peoples of color contrary to their
stated purpose of lifting us up are
placing boots on our necks what legy is
being left by Dei policies as I listen
to whites tell me all the things that
need to be done to make my life equal to
their own I hear the ideologies behind
their words I hear them telling me that
people or color are an inferior race
that is incapable of rising to the
challenges handed them at this hour I
hear them telling me that the only way
that our people can be successful in
life is if other races cheat at life for
us by giving us a head start I hear them
saying there is no value in my people
except the value endowed by their great
white
benefactors it is the same racist
ideology that kept people in the chains
of slavery The Anthem that sings that we
are but animals in need of being kept
but now it is slavery of the mind it
seems that the governing mentality still
expects our peoples to stand in line for
handouts from said benefactors do you
not realize that you are simply creating
a new reality in which your whites are
still the
oppressors the only difference is that
now you oppress our minds with thoughts
that we cannot be equal you despair
enourage us with statements that only
you can lift us up that our peoples lack
the strength to do so on our own you Dam
us to the slavery of never being capable
of catching our own
fish perhaps you think that these
policies will help that might be what
whites thought when the laws that sent
people to the homes of my mother and
others like her in the middle of the
night searching under the beds of her
and her siblings making certain that her
father was not in the home helping to
provide for them lest their government
Aid be taken from them my mother learned
to hate your handouts and it is a legacy
that I respect and will continue with my
own children all handouts come at a cost
of humiliating the recipients they
intend to help I'm sure that's not what
you meant to do you might even think
you're helping but by the time the ink
is draw on the lies you laws you have
passed another family is broken another
head droops in shame and
humiliation so perhaps you should
reconsider your choices we've done this
before and now an entire race suffers
from the damning pandemic of
fatherlessness the unintended
consequences of your help did not
benefit us before please don't help us
now sincerely T
Johnson please vote red on this
misplaced repeal Bill and keep our
anti-discrimination law in place thank
you and Mr Speaker I would like a roll
call on
pigo thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues New Hampshire is
currently struggling with the teacher
shortage in fact recently the committee
to study New Hampshire teacher shortages
and recruitment incentives completed its
findings among which teachers reported
that the increased politicization of
their jobs has discouraged many away
from the profession and that they are
feeling stress with concerns for
consequences as a result of legislation
proposed and passed by
us it is my hope that today we'll take a
step in addressing our teachers concerns
by overtraining one of those
laws titled the right to freedom from
discrimination in the workplace and
education yet despite its
title it has nothing to do with real
discrimination it should have no place
on the books in our honorable State one
which never received a standalone vote
in this chamber but instead was pushed
through as part of the budget in
2021 it is an insult to our Public
School teachers and it gives cover to
those who actually hate and are
discriminatory
in my testimony before the education
committee I said not everyone who agrees
with this law is a
racist but everyone who is racist
supports this
law
well the following day the house will be
in order the following day I received a
hateful email from a self-avowed
racist who also eviscerated me and the
members of this chamber for our views on
this law he quoted my remarks and then
he
said Peter is correct about that racists
support the current
law so let's take a close look at this
law it's comprised of four
Provisions which on the surface sound
perfectly reasonable until you examine
them
carefully Provisions a C and D are very
clear no pupil in any school public
school shall be taught that they are
superior that's provision a should
discriminate provision C or treat others
less than
equal provision
D seriously do we believe that our
public schools are instructing children
that they are
superior really should discriminate
treat others less than equal this is
where the law insults our teachers I
think of Marie my wife who taught
Elementary School in Milford for 30
years in her classroom she had a sign
which simply said the Golden Rule It Was
Written in gold colored letters it was
in a gold colored frame and she
explained to the children that out of
all the rules to follow this was the
most important
to treat others as equals with respect
and
kindness now while these Provisions
attempt to make the law sound
anti-discriminatory I believe that they
meant to camouflage the Law's real
intent which is found in provision
B that is to silence teaches voices on
topics that some don't want
discussed what does provision B
say no pupil in any public school shall
be taught that an individual or group is
inherently racist sexist or oppressive
now think about that for a moment think
about that for a moment are we denying
reality of course there are individuals
and groups which are racist sexist and
oppressive discriminatory to the lgbtq
plus Community anti-semitic islamophobic
and more our attorney general's office
has a list of these hate groups but
provision B prevents teachers from
saying so this right here is is the
Law's real
intent by the
way if I was
asked and I never was I would have
said you can always find examples of
those in every profession who violate
proper conduct but you don't paint
everyone with the same brush and imposed
Draconian measures which make it
challenging for everyone to do their
jobs the real question is this can a
teacher discuss the Holocaust without
making parallels to today's
neo-nazis or teach the history of the
Klux Clan without examining today's
white
supremacists I recently saw a post that
said education is not memorizing that
Hitler killed 6 million
Jews education is about understanding
how and why Millions of ordinary German
citizens allowed it to
happen the reason we study the past is
to understand how we got to where we are
today and to work towards making
tomorrow a better place for all of us
and we cannot do that if we're not
allowed to connect the
dots colleagues New Hampshire is better
than this we are better than this I I
urge you to vote ought to pass thank you
very much Mr
Speaker for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
postpone HB
1162 that is a proper motion roll call a
roll call has been requested by
representative Sweeny is that
sufficiently seconded it is officially
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
[Music]
seats
I
[Music]
clear
the motion before us is definely
postpone House Bill
1162 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative Pat
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that the
current law allows Educators to teach
and treat all equally and without
discrimination if I know that the
current law does not prohibit teachers
from teaching US history and does allow
for the teaching of historical concepts
related to discrimination and allows for
diverse educational approaches if I know
that repealing RSA 354 a29 through 354
a34 would eliminate any method of
redress for grievance of
discrimination would I now press the
green button and support the
indefinitely postponed motion chair
recognized representative luno for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know that all young people have a
First Amendment right to learn free from
censorship or discrimination including a
right to read learn and share ideas free
from Viewpoint based discrimin mintion
then wouldn't I press the red button to
defeat the uh inex the to to defeat the
um uh the motion the indefinite
postponement motion so that we can get
back on to um to this debate thank you
the motion before us is indefinitely
postpone House Bill 1162 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
second
while members present had opportunity to
vote 192 voting aay 183 voting aay House
postponed for what reason does a member
rise and move that the remarks from the
previous debate be printed in the
permanent journal without
objection
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill
1265 act relative to the penalty for
failure to file School expenditure
reports relative to certain adequacy
grants considered the same report the
same recommendation the bill ought to
pass pres of Rick lad for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those Close n
the eyes have it and the committee
adopted
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1305 FN relative to
freedom of speech and Association at
public institutions of higher
education pres of beler moves ought to
pass committee amendment is
0654 printed in house record 10 page 45
are you ready for the question on the
committee Amendment all those in favor
say I I those oppose
nay
[Music]
a division has been
called only members in the chamber can
verville members need to be in their
seats only members in the chamber can
come in and
vote this the question is on the
amendment
0654 this is for
clarification if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
for
represent
Mason
all members present and opportunity to
vote 181 voting aay 182 voting aay the
motion fails
for what reason does the member rise
thank you Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I move reconsideration
on that last vote urge the members to
vote we' moved on it's allowed we move
we moved on it's allowed now we're going
to a roll call vote this is on this is
on a motion for reconsideration on the
amendment on the
good
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill
amendment which is
0654 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor of
reconsideration you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting station are open
seconds
[Music]
Wellman was president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote under 189 voting a 183 voting a
reconsideration passes now back on the
amendment are you ready for the question
division
okay uh we ask for a division has been
requested all members take your seats it
anyways
the motion before us is on the amendment
H this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
seconds
[Music]
represent
McKenzie all members presentent had an
opportunity to vote house V attend to
vote under 192 voting yay 182 voting a
committee amendment is adopted bills on
second reading open to further Amendment
representa Popovich Muller offers floor
Amendment
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
support um amendment 10 94h when started
uh when I started working on this bill I
engaged with the university
representatives from the beginning and I
continue to work with them through all
this time The Minority Report see states
that the bill does not include any
feedback from the University system even
though when I tabled HB 516 last year I
told everybody here that the university
system had required a change to limit
their financial liability that change
has been made in 1305 as amended so I
have to correct the record and say that
the bill as filed already had feedback
included feedback from the University
system we just adopted 065 06 54h same
process somebody raised concerns the of
the Civil Rights unit of the Attorneys
General I worked with them to address
their concerns the amendment literally
contained the language that the
Attorneys General suggested to fix this
bill it had been adopted by the
committee 128 same process was used to
come up with this amendment I continue
to work with the university
representatives and we found two minor
changes that if made would make the bill
more palatable to them first we add two
words in the first paragraph of the
amendment to clarify that while the bill
does protect the rights of the members
of the Campus Community it does not
extend the same level of protections to
people unassociated with a university
that would just walk in from from the
street that was a reasonable concern and
I was happy to work with them to make
you know it better it also at the
request adds two instances where we
refer to reasonable time place and
manner restrictions to clarify that
those restrictions apply at all times I
originally felt that my bill language
made that clear to start with but after
hearing them tell me that it would be
better this way I was happy to you know
address that I'm not claiming by the way
that they will support this bill as
amended if they did we'd have a much uh
you know smaller floor discussion next
but they definitely prefer the bill as
amended here to the current language of
the bill they do support the amendment
10 94h so please show your support for
the University system by supporting
Amendment 1094 H which is filed at their
request thank you Mr Speaker I'm not
taking any questions and I request a
roll call
vote
J papovich Muller requested a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
C the motion before us is the papichi
Mueller floor Amendment
1094 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker um if I
know that uh that this bill has a lot of
problems with it and if I know that this
amendment doesn't fix any of them then
wouldn't I press the red button to
defeat the amendment thank
you chair recogniz braich Mueller for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this amendment is requested by the
university system would I press the
green button to show my support for them
thank
you the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1094 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent all members present have an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
vote 197 voting a 75 voting a the floor
amendment is adopted now we're on to a
to pass as Amendment chair recognizes
representer
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you honorable colleagues for allowing me
to speak today
I like to
talk a lot and both the New Hampshire
and US constitutions uphold that right
moreover First Amendment protections
expand far beyond speech and cover five
freedoms two of which are the subject of
House Bill
1305 speech and
Association more specifically House Bill
1305 relates to new Hampshire college
students however we are all students of
history and as many Statesmen who came
before us have noted quote I may
disagree with what you say but I will
defend your right to say it end quote As
We Gather in this historic chamber
representing the multitude of viewpoints
that Encompass the granite state these
words are relevant
today however student organizations are
incentivized to do the
opposite any person's misbehavior at an
event penalizes the student group
hosting the event therefore the hecklers
veto prohibits future events in other
words the student organization loses
their rights through no no fault of
their own not only is this unfair but
this is also
unamerican the absolute violation of
bothur constitutions renders the
university system open to expensive
lawsuits therefore House Bill 1305 is
Paramount to protecting taxpayers from
Financial Risk considering it is the
second most expensive State University
Nationwide the University of New
Hampshire is already a financial burden
needless to say litigation reduces
instructional resources increases tax
liability and is not conducive to
learning after all the purpose of
college is to get an
education furthermore House Bill 1305
aligns with Supreme Court rulings by
prohibiting
Free Speech zones in other words speech
should not be limited to the back corner
of the parking lot and prohibited
everywhere else finally last year a
similar bill was laid on the table so
not debated today New Hampshire students
are not only listening to this debate
but also want to know which
representatives defend
Freedom so Mr Speaker on their behalf I
request a roll call vote thank you J
wheeler thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise before you today because
the co-sponsor of the bill or the prime
sponsor of the bill asked me as a
co-sponsor to come speak before you
today about the importance of freedom of
speech and Mr Speaker it's a pleasure to
finally be able to get to speak on the
same side as the of the aisle as my
friend from Salem uh she's a passionate
individual a young person who has spent
a lot of time here and it's a it's a
great thing to be able to get to speak
with her this bill very simple there's a
problem in our schools right now that
students have been reporting for
unfortunately a long time their free
speech has been hampered and this is
students both conservative students
liberal students socialist students and
libertarian students people have had
their ability to speak on issues Stamper
by college administrators who are trying
their hardest to keep things nice
unfortunately for those who want to keep
things nice and calm and respectful
sometimes freedom of speech requires us
to be a little bit passionate it
requires us to say something that the
majority majority of the people in the
room might disagree with uh in fact
that's what protests is all about and Mr
Speaker this bill was worked on
extraordinarily hard for the last bium
as a matter of fact it was introduced in
the beginning of this bium and now we
are here towards the end of it debating
the final version of this bill the
sponsor worked with the Civil Rights
division of the AG's office to make sure
that it fits and is comp iant with what
they need to do in that office making
sure that it doesn't have any civil
rights violations in it and they worked
very hard with the university the system
to make sure that it met their concerns
and this is important because this
government this country in this world
depends on the Constitution that we have
here in the United States of America
there are many countries in this world
that don't have basic foundational
constitutional rights and they look to
the United States of America are red
white and blue stripes for inspiration
for those constitutional rights and if
we here in this body today don't say
that our students on the institutions
where they're learning have those
constitutional rights freedom of
Association freedom of speech we all
know the Gambit that I think we're
failing them because our institutions of
Educational Learning our especially our
higher instit in our higher education
institutions should be places where we
can can vociferously debate these issues
where everybody from every side can come
and tell why or why not they have the
beliefs that they do and yes sometimes
those beliefs will be abhorent to most
of us that's what freedom of speech is
about the founders were smart they were
intelligent and they knew that the
minority view needed to be protected in
a constitutional republic if it was to
survive
it's the first amendment isn't for
things that we all agree about you know
I I don't need the First Amendment to
protect me from my right to say that
puppies are cute I think most of us
agree puppies are cute I need my first
amendment rights to protect me from
people who would prosecute me for my
position on something that they don't
agree with Min someone Prosecuting a
minority view so Mr Speaker to protect
our educational institutions and make
sure that speak and debate is had in a
full throated way and understanding the
very diligent work that was put into
this bill I urge you to join me
representative McDonald the young people
of this body and everybody in here who
loves freedom of speech in supporting
the ought to pass motion on this
legislation thank
luno thank you m Mr Speaker I'm here to
speak in opposition to House Bill
1305 make no mistake I'm in favor of
free speech and free speech on our
college
campuses and while the bill has some
good
aspects they're already being done
throughout the state's University and
Community College systems and are
included in free speech policies at UNH
Plymouth Keane and all the community
colleges UNH is ranked third in the
country among all colleges and
universities for its policies on free
speech and expression and all of our
state's fouryear institutions receive
green lights from the foundation for
individual rights and expression this
unnecessary but most importantly the
bill overreaches far beyond speech and
expression and we haven't talked about
this
yet it requires our state colleges and
universities to recognize student
organizations that discriminate on the
basis of race gender religion and
political
ideology and the bill would require UNH
and the other colleges and universities
to fund these
groups some of them being hate groups
with money coming from taxpayers tuition
and
fees are you kidding really is this what
New Hampshire is all about out this bill
fuels a divisive environment on campus
and it violates our state's own
anti-discrimination laws and federal law
such as Title 9 taxpayers and families
expect better the sponsors ignored input
and feedback from the universities and
community
colleges bills like this would promote
discrimination and hate speech and
should be resoundingly rejected press
the red button if you support
anti-discrimination and you know there's
a lot of unh graduates here in New
Hampshire and they want to know what
side you're on so I'm going to stand by
and request the roll call vote as well
on this Mr speaker so that they know
Muller thank you Mr chair and
distinguished colleagues I rise
today oh Mr
Speaker a good start
my apologies I rise today to cor correct
a lot of misinformation about this bill
I shared the package of documents and
videos with all of you ahead of time I
don't need to keep my cards close to my
chest I'd rather have you give give you
the time to consider everything at
length I could address The Minority
Report point that we're doing great and
we are ranked third by fire but our fire
score is of only 72 out of 100 which is
a rather mediocre C minus I think it's
perfectly reasonable to to ask our
University to do better I could remind
you that UC Berkeley went from being the
heart of the Free Speech movement to
suffering from repeated cases of
violence being used to suppress speech
just like upen went from being against
free speech to being for free speech to
again being against Free Speech we have
a duty to set standards and make sure
that our universities respect Free
Speech permanently so this legislation
is needed I could spend time to address
the other part in claim that HB 30305
and I quote violates our state's own dis
non-discrimination laws and federal law
but to take that claim seriously you'd
have to believe that nobody noticed it
until now because nobody testified
against it in committee you'd have to
believe that the ACLU endorsed this bill
two years in a row because they just
didn't notice it was dismantling our
anti-discrimination laws which ACLU is
defending so
staunchly and you'd have to believe that
the director of the Civil Rights
after a thorough review of this bill
also failed to notice that this bill
disc dismantles the statutes that the
office you know of the Civil Rights unit
is designed to protect here so why the
opposition to this bill if you took the
10 minutes that I asked you for when I
sent you that email yesterday to watch
the videos you already know this
publicly stated desire to ban student
associations with beliefs one finds
repugnant is very understandable it's
human nature but acting on such desires
is unconstitutional and a terrible
policy we cannot and should not punish
People based on content of their lawful
speech regardless of how repugnant we
may find it free speech is the
Cornerstone of our nation tampering with
it is
foolish I want to remind you that a lot
of commonly accepted beliefs today have
been considered repugnant at the
beginning Abol ISM was considered
repugnant and it was attacked because of
claims of emotional harm against the
slave
owners women's rights were considered a
repugnant idea how dare you you gay
rights were so Radioactive in the 50s
that the ACL refused to even represent
them it took another decade until the
ACLU was comfortable enough so many
ideas are strong today because someone
protected them the First Amendment
against the people who wanted to silence
them until they grew into the supported
ideas that are today the freedom of
Association bans all Commerce policies
which would require every Student
Association to accept every
member those policies are discriminatory
in intent and in application because to
apply them literally the way they are
written would require every University
to remove every safe space because every
safe space is discriminatory that way
you don't allow everybody in nobody
intends to do that and they shouldn't
all we are asking for is the same
treatment for everybody to have their
own safe spaces to meet should apply to
everyone same thing with the minimal
funds that they get from the University
which by the way come from Student
Activity fees not taxpayer money not
tuition funds Student Activities fees
from the people you know who attend
there is no requirement for the
University to offer any funds to any
Student Association the bill simply says
that if you do it you got to give it to
everybody equally
you don't have to if you find that
objectional equal protection under the
law equal rights for everyone that is
all we are asking for The Minority
Report also appears to consistently
confuse discrimination which is legal
and good with illegal discrimination
which is based on belonging to a
protected class which is bad and illegal
UNH discriminates against every student
they reject should they accept everybody
who
applies does the school dis discriminate
against athletically challenged students
by not letting a 5 foot student who's
weighing 100 pound play nose tackle or
Center on the basketball team how dare
you
discriminate seriously and please please
try to imagine a world in which you
would be legally required to date
anybody who asks you out because to deny
somebody's discriminatory of course it's
not illegally discriminatory thank God
nobody suggesting those policies are
good by by the the same token all
Commerce policies are terrible so we
should make sure they don't come in but
for the record illegal discriminations
are still the red hering every example
of undesirable student associations
discussed in hearings both in 2023 and
24 was based on their beliefs speech and
expression whether it was their
purported support for genocide or their
Neo-Nazi membership or white
supremacists or
anti-semitic if even members of the
education committee cannot resist the
unconstitutional desire to ban certain
student associations in order to
suppress speech they find repugnant what
chance does the faculty staff and
student membership have to resist the
same Temptation This by the way is
precisely the type of student ban that
victims testified about in 2023 and I am
dismayed by the fact that people who
watch this testimony are trying to
oppose the bill that's trying to prevent
f their abuses and by the way another
one of those situations happened later
in 2023 reminding us of a need to pass
this bill to make it crystal clear to
everyone that we do not tolerate such
actions in the state of New Hampshire
I'm asking you all to reject these
attempts to enable oppression of
minorities based on their beliefs lawful
beliefs and speech and protect all
members of the Campus Community by
supporting the OTP motion for this
bipartisan Bill thank you Mr Speaker I
will not be taking any questions and I
do also request a roll call vote thank
you I was just going to ask if the
member yielded the questions no no
yield the motion before us is how to
pass as amended on House Bill 1305 a
roll call has been requested members uh
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
vote
for
the the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on House Bill
1305 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
university and Community College systems
of New Hampshire already have effective
policy standards for free speech and
expression and are highly ranked
nationally for their Fair application of
those policies and if I know that this
bill would require our state colleges
and universities to recognize and fund
organizations that discriminate on the
basis of race gender religion and
political ideology and if I know that
despite its title this bill actually
violates our state non-discrimination
laws would I now press the red button
thank you chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that freedom of expression and
freedom of Association are under attack
in this country particularly in our
academic institutions which should be
the last place we would expect this to
occur and if I know that although New
Hampshire Public colleges and
universities Faire better in this regard
than private colleges and universities
and those in some other states our
public institutions of Higher Learning
have not been immune to the uh to the
scourge of political correctness and if
I know that championing champion
championing diversity is the cause celeb
in the academic world as to all things
but one that exception being diversity
of thought and if I know that HB 1305
enhances freedom of expression and
freedom of Association on our Public
University campuses while giving
administrators ample authority to impose
reasonable time place and manner
limitations on these rights and finally
Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill does not and
could not under the supremacy clause uh
authorize the university system to
sanction unlawful discrimination based
on race sex or any other protected class
uh then would I support the OTP motion
by pushing the green button thank you Mr
vote the motion before us is aop pass as
amended on House Bill 1305 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
all members present opportunity to vote
vote 206 voting aay 169 voting nay the
adopted for what reason does a member
rise I move that the remarks from the
previous debate be printed in the
permanent
objection committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 1311
relative to school district collection
development and reconsideration policies
this comes without recommendation of
Milo moves ought to pass chair
recognizes representative
corello what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
1311 that is a proper motion the
motion uh that is a proper motion and a
roll call has been requested by
representative Sween is that it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
somebody
do doing a view represent paig you
should go back to your seat you should
seat
the motion before us is indefinitely
postponement on House Bill
1311 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative lad for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know it's time to clean up our
green chair recognized representative
brenon for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
we have shared goals in preserving local
control and the freedom to read while
ensuring due process for parents
increase transparency and clear policies
complying with New Hampshire laws
against discrimination would I now press
the red button so that we can move on to
a proper motion thank
you the motion before us is definitely
postponement on House Bill 1311 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button oppos
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
Thomas while members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
vote 185 voting a 190 voting a the
motion for indef postpone moment fails
we're back to to the original motion of
a to pass chair recognizes
representative
quartell thank you Mr
Speaker those who support HB
1311 refer to it euphemistically as as
the freedom to read bill it requires
school districts to adopt policies
concerning the selection of Library
materials as well as their
removal supporters assert that it will
effectively ban all book bans encourage
intellectual freedom and discourage
discrimination this all sounds wonderful
until you look more deeply into what
this bill really does HB 1311 makes it
impossible for local school boards to
remove material that parents subject to
a 2017 article on the American Library
association's intellectual Freedom blog
emphasizes one of the basic ideas from
the famous 1982 Supreme Court case Board
of Education versus
Pico and I quote School boards are
responsible for supervising the
education of students who are in their
care and can remove materials deemed
educationally unsuitable or pervasively
vulgar those last two phrases are from
the actual Supreme Court decision so
let's stop calling every removal of a
book from a library a book
ban this term is misused when describing
this bill because removing a book from
the relatively small sort of collections
in public school libraries and action
that both the Pico case and this article
on the Ala website affirm is sometimes
Justified does not prevent anyone from
getting that book somewhere else whether
it be Amazon a bookstore or even from
another
Library HB 1311 prohibits the removal of
materials based on the author's or
character's age sex gender identity race
and a number of other protected
categories this criteria would
hypothetically justify the inclusion of
a blind author's treaties on the joys of
pedophilia because of his physical
disability so what this so-called
freedom to read Bild really requires
isn't anything Go's collection
development policy that abuses true
Freedom Frederick Douglas asserted that
learning to read makes a person forever
free the freedom that he referred to
does not hinge on the ability of a child
to access books that are as the Supreme
Court specify educationally unsuitable
or pervasively vulgar HB 1311 further
prohibits the removal of Library
material on the basis of viewpoint so
actually the author in the previous
example wouldn't even have to be
disabled because his opinions on
pedophilia would be protected simply
because they were his viewpoint
similarly a howto book like one I found
on Amazon suicide methods for a safe and
peaceful death could hypothetically be
selected by a very misguided Public
School librarian and would be off limits
for
reconsideration because the author's
Viewpoint is that all readers should
have easy access to information on how
to kill
themselves freedom to read should not
mean anything goes it should not mean
that books considered objectionable can
never be removed freedom is actually
being denied by this so-called freedom
to read bill the freedom of parents to
object to a book and have that objection
seriously considered not discounted and
undermined by Twisted logic that judges
a book by the identity of its authors
and characters rather than on the
content of its Pages since HB 13 11
lacks Common Sense offers no solution to
the problem of children's exposure to
harmful Library material and only makes
the problem
worse the ought to pass motion must be
opposed thank you Mr Speaker I request a
roll call
Paige thank you Mr Speaker
when it comes to addressing
controversial materials in our school
libraries we have a
choice we can Retreat to our
Corners try to score
points and make accusations against one
another or we can agree to turn down the
temperature and ask whether we might
actually share the same values and
goals
do we all want high quality School
library collections for our
kids do we all want due process for
concerned parents Schoolboard
transparency and local control over
school
policy do we value the Bedrock principle
of
non-discrimination and support students
access to diverse books and multiple
points of
view do we support the first First
Amendment rights of
students HB 1311 is a
bipartisan Common Sense bill which takes
a balanced approach in upholding all of
these shared goals and I ask for your
support under this legislation districts
must adopt two
policies first a collection development
policy which clearly Del Ates what
criteria staff will use When selecting
books and other materials for the
library common criteria in such policies
include curricular fit authoritativeness
of the information and materials
developmental
appropriateness
second the bill requires a
reconsideration
policy which describes the process that
the school will follow when addressing
parent requests to remove
materials these policies are already
widely recognized as best practice in
school librarianship and they will
simply be required rather than
recommended should this bill
pass these two policies must be in
substantial compliance with New
Hampshire law against
discrimination this includes ensuring
that policies do not exclude books based
solely on an author or subject's
identity within a protected class such
as race or sexual
orientation but to be crystal
clear this does not mean as some have
argued that a book with a black
character or a gay character or a blind
character could never be removed for any
reason merely that it cannot be removed
because of their
identity this provision recognizes that
while many requests for removal are made
in good faith
others have been made with the goal of
removing diverse perspectives from the
stacks of the 2,000
2,000 different books different titles
that have been targeted for removal in
schools in the United States last year
nearly three qus were by or about black
people people of color or lgbtq
people District policies must
additionally avoid view viewpoint-based
discrimination this is not a republican
issue or a Democratic issue this is a
First Amendment
issue and as the Supreme Court ruled in
Pico when defining Viewpoint based
discrimination school boards may not
remove books in seeking to quote
prescribe what shall be Orthodox in
politics nationalism religion or other
matters of
opinion regardless of which side of the
aisle you stand on this body should
stand stand on the side of the freedom
to read and against censorship in our
ideas HB 1311 is common sense bipartisan
legislation which equips us to prevent
discrimination preserve local control
and guarantee that concerned parents and
Guardians receive due process it is
rooted in a deep respect for fundamental
principles of free expression and the
diverse students and families we
serve New Hampshire school libraries
offer students a window into a world
beyond their
backyards through the library kids
encounter new ideas that enrich their
lives contribute to their academic
achievement and Foster empathy for
people different from
themselves the school librarians who
work in our libraries are highly trained
passionate professionals whose job it is
to support each student in collaboration
with that students family to find the
just right books for them and ignite a
lifelong love of
reading I hope you will join me in
supporting our school libraries and the
kids who use them and join this bill's
bipartisan co-sponsors in voting for
this pragmatic
Speaker
we have we have a request for roll call
is that officially
seconded it is officially seconded this
will be a roll call
seats just so everybody knows we're
going to be taking this final we're
going to be taking this vote and then go
to recess we do have a medical problem
over
here
SE
down
she's
[Music]
here
Prof
the members need to be in their seats
you
me
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill
1311 this is going to be a roll call
vote J recognized representative Noble
inquiry thank you Mr Mr
Speaker if I know that no material
should be selected for a school library
or prevented from removal based on
characteristics or identity of the
author or
subject if I know that a child should be
protected from obscene material instead
of granting them the freedom to read it
and if I know that this bill would do
nothing but cement obscene material
right into the school libraries but is
masquerading as a solution then would I
button you recognize representa Brendan
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this bill is a bipartisan
solution to an all to Common issue
facing our our communities creating
increased Division and disruption and if
I know we have shared goals in
preserving local control and the freedom
to read while ensuring due process for
parents increased transparency and clear
policies complying with New Hampshire
laws against
discrimination and Mr Speaker if I know
every person including students deserves
the opportunity to find themselves in a
book
and explore the world beyond their
doorstep through literature and this
bipartisan Common Sense solution strikes
the right balance between parental
rights First Amendment rights and local
control would I now show Granite Staters
that working together on shared goals is
possible in 2024 and press the green
button to press h to pass HB 1311 thank
you the motion before this is all to
pass on House Bill 1311 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your appros
press a red button voting stations is
seconds
[Music]
youread while members of presid have
opportunity to vote household tend to
vote 194 voting aay 180 voting
nay we're going to go immediately to
lunch you can do your reconsideration
afterwards we're going to go immediately
to lunch I want everybody to stay away
from this back door here when you uh go
out of the chamber go out against these
here Rec the house will be in recess
1:20
e
ucation to which was referred House Bill
1312 requiring parental notification of
student health or well-being and certain
curricul by school districts sen of
cadelli moves ought to
pass Amendment
0774 H printed in house record 10 pages
45 through 46 are you ready for the
motion on the uh question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the I the eyes have it the amendment
is
adopted the chair recognized
representative
Damon
thank you Mr
Speaker the how the house will be in
order member has a right to be
heard thank you
again the word fear is sometimes viewed
as an acronym false evidence appearing
Real This Acronym describes how our
minds can weave together false Tales of
how situations might turn out as I
described the adverse
consequences we should expect if HB 1312
passes please consider if your position
is determined by fear rather than by
facts HB 13312 is unnecessary
legislation created by fear of the
unfamiliar or unknown this bill would
cause censoring in health education
classes and in all other instruction and
curriculum that reference lgbtq
people it could apply to books assigned
in history class on women achieving the
right to vote on marriage equality on
the Stonewall Uprising and so much more
the very broad scope of 1312 would
severely impair thorough honest
education thus harming all students
it is completely
impractical many of us could share our
stories of first learning that a family
member or friend has a different gender
identity than the familiar
heterosexual how we move from Fear
concern and
uncertainty to recognizing that we are
all just people trying to live our best
lives is a complex multi-chapter journey
I believe the supporters of HB 1312 live
in fear of harm by those who are
them but the real harm from 1312 is that
it interferes with the ability of our
professional Educators to provide valid
comprehensive curriculum as well as to
support teens throughout their growth
New Hampshire education statutes already
require schools to provide parents with
a two-e advance notice of curriculum
course materials dealing with human
sexuality parents already have the
option to remove their child from
instruction and course material they
consider
objectionable schools already respect
that parents should be involved in their
children's education and want them to
participate School Personnel do
encourage students to directly talk with
parents but mandating disclosure taking
away discretion is harmful to those very
students we want to
support the divisive and dangerous
ramifications of this bill are
many respecting gender education does
not erase people that you don't
understand or prefer rather it sends the
message that the feelings and identities
of Youth are to be shunned feared and
potentially even censored very sadly and
most unkindly it would Short change all
of us from the opportunities to better
understand and
connect HB 1312 proposes a new section
of law dealing with the emotional
well-being and mental health of students
students all of us learn best when we
feel safe to be ourselves and can trust
teachers this bill puts in Jeopardy the
highly successful on trusted abult
program that was adopted by the
Department of Education from the
Governor's School Safety task force
recommendation
one trusted adult encourages students to
have a trusted adult at school someone
to talk with to prevent bullying address
substance abuse promote positive
self-worth and create a safe place for
learning you can't learn if you don't
feel
safe this bill would prevent young
people from discussing sensitive
subjects with trusted adults at school
which is especially valuable as they are
preparing to have those discussions with
their parents the vast majority of
parents only want to do what is best for
their child schools however cannot fully
anticipate circumstances where this bill
would prompt instances of abuse should a
parent react poorly to the information
they have requested about their child it
needs to be up to the students to
communicate with parents when the time
is right for them instead of limiting
education
our schools should protect and support
all students to learn and Thrive please
press the red button to defeat OTP so a
better motion can be made thank you J
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker you just heard a lot about
fear but it doesn't come from the
supporters of this bill this bill does
two common sense things to support
families first current law requires that
District
policies uh for parents be notified two
weeks in advance when instructions or
programs on human sexuality or sex
education are to be provided so they can
opt their child out if they so
choose this bill simply adds sexual
orientation gender identity or gender
expression to those lists of
instructions or programs
requiring advanced
notice the second thing the amended Bill
does is to prohibit districts from
adopting policies that would prevent
schools from answering a parents
question about their child's emotional
or physical health sexuality or a change
in their
services don't parents have a right to
know do we want School staff withholding
answers
from parents keeping secrets if you will
whose kids are they
anyway any policy that would keep
answers from parents is destructive it
would destroy the relationship between
parents and child and it would also
destroy trust between parents and
schools this should not be hard just
tell parents the truth when they ask
simple there is a protection in the
bill if Al providing this
information a reasonably a reasonably
prudent person would believe that
disclosure would lead to abuse or
neglect they could withhold that
information the opposing committee
report states that this bill is divisive
and
dangerous dangerous for who for the
relationship between the child and the
parent and the family I asked a moment
ago who children are they anyway well I
believe that some want to insert the
government into a parenting uh into a
parenting
role we heard that there should be a
trusted adult at school but evidently
not at
home it's very simple let parents know
when instructions to be given about
sexuality gender and identity and
secondly just tell parents the truth
representative grer has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
clear
the motion before is ought to pass on
House Bill 1312 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Woodcock
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that HB 1312 goes far
beyond just amending curriculum policy
notifications and timelines for
parents and if I know that under the new
section that was written that if for
example High School teenager student
came to me as his teacher or coach to
discuss any questions about any issue of
importance to them that may range from
date rape to hazing soliciting relevant
information I am forbidden to say why
don't you just think it over before you
make a decision and if I know that under
this law I would be restricted from
suggest suggesting to that student that
maybe they should discuss that with a
guidance counselor a school social
worker medical doctor or perhaps a
professional from their particular Faith
then knowing all this to be true I ask
the members of this house to press the
red button and support a student's
request for help and support thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognizes
representative Alicia leas for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know know that
parents behave have the ultimate
responsibility of caring for and about
their children and if I know this is
very difficult to do if they're not
informed of what's going on with and
what's being taught to their children
and finally if I want to give them every
opportunity to succeed in raising their
children would I now push the green
button to pass this important
bill the motion before us is a pass on
House Bill 1312 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 186 voting yay 185 voting aay
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1512 FN limiting
education Freedom account funding to
budgeted
amounts representative milu M ought to
cordelli
thank you Mr
Speaker an attack or guard
rail supporters of this bill view it as
a guard rail for a program that has been
over budgeted I beg to differ this has
been a very successful program demand
has outpaced the budget estimates Su
successful in in that almost 5,000
students already take advantage of the
program successful in that parents find
it beneficial to their children as
evidenced by the fact that stay students
are staying in the program and not
leaving to go back to their Public
School 1512 would cap establishment of
EFA Accounts at the amount in the banal
budget there was testimony that if this
cap was reached a warrant article could
simply be drawn by the governor to put
more money into the budget but that's
not what the bill
says the bill specifically says that any
warrant cannot exceed the budgeted
amount we always hear that the program
exceeds budget each year well that
budgeted amount is really just an
estimate of the number of kids who are
going to enroll in the program
the number of kids who make a
choice this is different than public
schools which have zip code locked
population maybe we should hold public
schools to a budgeted amount
also and think of it this way when more
children take advantage of the E efas
and the program amount
increases doesn't that save taxpayers
money
consider thank you uh consider the
average EFA amount is about
$5,200 while a public school student
cost to taxpayers is about
$22,000 this is not common core
math so this bill places a hard cap on
the program it places a limit on the
number of kids who can take advantage of
the program the number of kids who are
trying to find an option for their
education that meets their
needs so you tell me is this an attack
or a guard rail if you believe that
every child deserves the education that
will meet their unique individual needs
then this is an attack and it needs to
be defeated defend kids and taxpayers
Miler thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I arise today to urge you and
urge this body to support the OTP
motion this bill aners a simple
question like all other state budgeted
programs should the education Freedom
account program stay within the adopted
State budgeted
amount simple
question in the first year of the
$129,000 the actual cost was
$8.1
million or a $7.9 million over
budget in the second year the budget was
$3.2
million and the actual cost was
$14.7
million or $1.5 million over
budget the third-year budget was
$19.8
million and the expense to date was 22.2
million or 2.4 million over
budget now these figures attest that
over the past three years the program
has exceeded the budget of allocation by
$
21.8
million currently the EFA program is
essentially an open checkbook to funding
approved
request there is no restraint on the
projected budget of over 30 to $60
million projected in the
future this is not a minor expense to
the
state frankly the Department of
Education needs to do a better job in
projecting the anticipated cost of this
program so my colleagues as you consider
your position on HB
1512 I ask you this
question should the education Freedom
account program be administered
accordingly to The Proven State
restrictions and mandates limited to
their budget
allocation if your answer is
yes please support the OTP motion thank
vote we sen Miler requested a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
[Music]
e
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 1512 this is a roll call vote
chair recognize representative lad for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the education Freedom account
program on average cost
$5,200 far less than the cost per pupil
in traditional schools and if I also
know this program is yet another attempt
to limit student enrollment and funding
when in fact the New Hampshire EFA
program is a model for States across
this country while receiving top
National
accolades would I then press the red
button to reject limiting EFA enrollment
and funding thank
you chair Reon cascaden for for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire state
funded programs are implemented at the
utmost transparency and financial
accountability to our local taxpayers if
I know that all state funded programs
except education Freedom accounts must
follow mandatory budgeting restrictions
and requirements and if I want to ensure
our Collective fiduciary duties to New
Hampshire constituents then would I not
vote Yes by pressing the green button
thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1512 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
e
all members president had an opportunity
vote 186 voting yay 187 voting nay the
speaker did
vote for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I move indefinitely
postpone on HB
1512 and I'd like a roll call vote Mr
Speaker the motion before us is to
definitely postpone
1512 representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
seats
the motion before us is endeav
postponement on House Bill 1512 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor you
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
represent all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 187 voting a 185 voting aay HB 15
postponed committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 1594 FN
establishing an annual review and
qualification to determine eligibility
to participate in the education Freedom
accounts program sen Milo moves on to
pass for what reason does the member
1594 there is a motion to indefinitely
spone house postpone House Bill
1594 representative Sweeney has
requested representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that's
officially seconded is officially
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats Mr
Speaker I would like to move to lay it
table okay that is a higher motion
laying on the table already put question
already put the question too late
the he's put the question I thought he
would had just asked for the seconds for
the roll
call
okay motion before us in defly
motion before us is in depth
postponement on House Bill 1594 this is
a roll call vote chair recognizes
representative cordelli for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill would
actually turn kids into
yo-yos if I know that a parent whose
income can fluctuate from year to year
would take the child in and out of the
program from year to year it sure sounds
like a yo-yo to
me and if I know that this bill is
actually for the kids
would I vote for the indefinite
postponement by pressing the green
button do I recognize represent of PA
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the education
Freedom account program was introduced
as a poverty program and if I know the
participants in newers numerous poverty
programs including EFA students who
participate in the free and reduced
meals program
must be annually recertified to ensure
that family income is within the poverty
level
threshold and if I know that EFA
students who end up not qualifying in
subsequent years because of increased
family income can continue to attend
their school of
choice and if I like the bill for these
reasons would I now press the red button
to listen to debate thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is in depth
postponement on House Bill 1594 this the
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote 189 voting a 184 voting a house
bill 5094 is and definitely
post
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred House Bill
1671 FN act relative to the complaint
process for teaching discrimination and
allowing Educators and school officials
a right of action for damages and cost
for false accusations having considered
the s report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate Senator Rick lad for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
a report with a recommendation to Bill
ought to pass s of Lind Linder Tanner
for the minority of the committee the
question before us is the majority
committee report of of uh inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I
nay
adopted committee on Election law to
which was referred cacr 19 relating to
redistricting providing that an
independent redistricting commission
shall be established to draw boundaries
for state and federal Offices it comes
without recommendation representative
Lane moves ought to pass offers for
Amendment
0910 printed in house record 10 pages
37-42 the question is on the amendment
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it in the
amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes representative
B
thank you Mr Speaker CAC r19 I'm here to
speak against the
OTP and deja vu all over again
originally I was going to look up my
speech from two terms
ago when this also came up and there's
another one coming
this amendment would this bill would
create an unworkable solution it calls
for Democrats Republicans and
Independence where does one find an
independent check the voting roles on
how an independent voted in the primary
then are they an
independent or find someone that has
never voted do you want them on a
commission and in the past we have had
census delayed by the federal government
so in that case how can the commission
deliver the findings in the time period
specified how many times do we have to
vote on a
commission this has failed numerous
times the current method is fine and the
only problem that I've seen in the
redistricting for the last three
times is when the governor has
interfered and where in the New
Hampshire constitution does it give the
governor the power and then the Court's
doing it and we keep hearing about Jerry
mandering in the 16 years I've been here
we have had equal numbers of Democrat
and Republican majorities if we had
jeram mandering that wouldn't happen
Senate and Executive councils also keep
changing but then congressional
districts seem to be always the same so
maybe there is so please vote red so we
can move on thank you
mad thank you Mr
Speaker the process we go through every
10 years of drawing District boundaries
should be a fair process one that people
of all parties can agree to but the
process that we have is not one that
people consider Fair who likes a system
where politicians
draw electoral maps that benefit
politicians the answer is only
politicians voters do not like partisan
Jerry mandering according to a recent
poll taken after the last election 88%
of trump
voters do not like do not approve of
partisan Jerry mandering almost a
similar percentage of Biden voters
reject partisan Jerry mandering it's one
of the only issues
that joins stalwart supporters of each
of those
candidates Jerry mandering is the kind
of thing that turns ordinary citizens
off to politics causes them to see the
unworthy in New
Hampshire it's resulted as the previous
speaker just pointed out in Governor's
vetoing Maps adopted by the legislature
which was done in 2002 2012 and last
time around it's resulted in courts
drawing District boundaries instead of
the
legislature it's not
working it's not working in the eyes of
institutionally one defense of partisan
Jerry mandering says
this that there's no way to get partisan
politics
out of the business of drawing District
boundaries so we might as well just let
the politicians do their
thing but there is a way there is an
alternative it's called independent
redistricting the word independent is a
slight
misnomer we're not calling on the angels
to come down from heaven and draw dis
boundaries with platonic
Perfection this is a human process it's
a process where the goal is to get
Democrats Republicans and independents
to agree on District
boundaries the idea is that it's
possible to lay down the rules of
democratic contestation of electoral
contestation in a way that all the
parties to the contest agree to just as
it's possible at the beginning of a
baseball game to have all the players
agree to the rules of baseball before
the game starts or before a game of
chess to have the two rival players
agree to the rules before they start
playing it's possible in politics too to
get basic rules of the game that all the
contenders agree to and that's not
Angelic Perfection that's just human
fairness it's worth striving
for
now if I'm wrong and the citizens of New
Hampshire want partisan Jerry
mandering this bill gives them the
chance to say so because this would just
put the question to the citizenry it
doesn't impose any policy on citizens it
just gives them a chance to say yes or
no to Independent redistricting give the
choice to
citizens
a green
vote lets citizens
decide pressing the red button says we'd
rather have partisan politicians draw
District boundaries for the benefit of
partisan politicians please vote green
thank you very much Mr Speaker roll Mr
Speaker the motion before us requ a roll
pass on CAC
r19 pres of Lane has requested a roll
call as that sufficiently seconded it is
officially seconded this will be a roll
seats
motion before us is ought to pass on
cacr 19 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative wood for
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr chair Mr
Speaker and fellow uh Representatives Mr
Speaker if I know that you can find
examples of the best efforts to
legislate the rules of the game to make
it as Fair as possible and these
attempts have given disastrous results
if I know between the Court's approvals
the governor's veto the special interest
groups the special agencies that put
influence there are already too many
people involved with the redistricting
process and finally if I know that this
political process is clearly in the
hands of us legislators no one else
would you press the red button so we can
make another motion so another motion
can be made thank you chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that most new Hamp sure voters were
disillusioned with the process that we
saw in
2021 and support an independent
redistricting commission and if I know
that drawing maps that everyone can
agree to and in a transparent way would
serve the interest better for the voters
and not the interest of us or our
parties and if I know that we each
represent constituents of both parties
and took an oath to support the
Constitution not our party then would I
push the green button to allow the
voters of New Hampshire to decide how
redistrict motion before us is a to pass
in cacr 19 this a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
yeah
[Music]
while members president had the ability
vote 186 voting nay 189 voting nay it
pass
for what reason the member
rise Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side of House Bill 1311 I
would move reconsideration and urge the
representative Sweeny has requested a
roll call I just haven't got around to
it yet I'll do it now resident Sweeny
has requested a roll call as that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
call
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill
1311 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent Roy and
texting while M was pres had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
vote 183 voting aay 192 voting nay the
motion
fails for what reason do the member rise
a question of the
speaker State your
question we just recently indefinitely
postponed a
bill relative to annual certification on
the education Freedom
accounts if the chamber behind us comes
up with an amendment to one of their
bills or sends over a bill that has
similar
happens this is something that has been
discussed numerous
times and initially we'll take a look at
it if the
chamber if if the if the language is
substantially simar if the language is
substantially Sim similar the changer
the chamber can vote to accept it we
would put the question to the body we
put the yeah we put the question to the
body we would take two3 to introduce
two-thirds so if I heard you
correctly if the language was
substantially similar regarding an
annual
certification then the question would be
put to the body and unless 2/3 voted for
it that would stop this correct
yes thank
you committee on Election law to which
was referred House Bill 1146 relative
the removal of a voter from the
recommendation representative Barry
moves ought to
rafter thank you Mr
chair if I know that this bill is unne
necessary because virtually no voters
request removal from the checklist and
if I know that voters are already
removed from the checklist when they
register in another district and if I
know that this would allow a voter to
remove their name immediately after an
election which could make it more
difficult to reconcile a vote or verify
a voter then would I vote would I press
the red button so another motion could
be made thank
you this is going to be a division vote
I made the mistake of not announcing
that at first this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative void for
a parliamentary inquiry thank thank you
Mr speaker thank you again Mr Speaker if
I know that in 2021 a quarter million
voters names no longer eligible to vote
were removed from the checklist that
took 10 years to accumulate because
there's no other way to remove them and
if I know that when you move to another
town There's no way to guarantee that
your name will be removed from the voter
list at your old address and finally if
I know that the checklist is available
to anyone and it should be your right to
moove your name from for any reason
in
leave the motion before us is a to pass
on House Bill
vote all those in favor will press the
green button all those opposed will
seconds
[Music]
all members present of the opportunity
to vote house attend to state of the
vote 186 voting a 183 voting aay Comm
report
we have a number of bills that are
coming up that are just going to be piis
and a division vote so if everybody will
stay in their seats for a few minutes we
them committee on Election law to which
referred House Bill 1310 n FN relative
to meetings supervisors of the checklist
sen of wary moves ought to pass this is
going to be a division
seats
motion before us a to pass and House
Bill 1310 this is a division boat chair
recognize representative Bay for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that supervisors of the checklist
are opposed to this bill because it's it
is prescriptive and yields no apparent
gains and if I know that
supervisors already meet at a Cadence
that works very well for their
respective
cities and if I know that meeting every
90 days is much more often than needed
for most municipalities especially the
small
towns would I then press the red button
to oppose the motion of autopass thank
you Mr Speaker chair recognize RAB for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill will provide a consistent
opportunity for municipalities to
properly maintain their voter checklists
and if I know that during a 2021 voter
role verification that nearly
250,000 voters needed to be purged for
reasons such as they had moved or they
had died would I now press the green
button so we can stay on top of this
vital
task the motion before first is ought to
pass on House Bill 1310 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose or
press a red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent of all members present had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote
188 voting yay 187 voting nay and the
vote committee on Election law to which
was referred House Bill 1348 relative to
polling places which total ballot counts
exceed the number of registered voters
pass and offers floor amendment is 0h
94h printed in house record 10 pages 46-
47 and we're going to have a division on
both right on both so there is a going
to be a division on the amendment and
then if that passes a division
the bill
itself for what reason member rise I
would like to make a motion please State
your motion I would like to table this
bill that is a correct motion so the
motion is to table House Bill
1348 and I'd like a I'd like a division
vote
please division roll sen who has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
[Music]
passes
all right the motion is to table House
Bill
1348 I'm sorry chair recognizes repres
not not yet chair recogniz represent
resentative waynee for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill addresses a situation
that won't never happen where more
ballots are cast than there are
registered voters and if I know that
there is an existing statute RSA
6593 that provides remedy if this highly
highly highly unlikely scenario
occurs then would I push the green
button and table this bill and reject
unproven conspiracy theories thank
you house will be in
order chair recognizes representative
Barry for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
we have had situations where vote counts
have exceeded reported vote counts have
exceeded the total number of registered
voters
would then Mr Speaker I press the red
button so that we can create a
prescriptive remedy for if that
situation
occurs the motion before us is to table
House Bill 1348 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppos or press the red
seconds
here
Smith all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 184 voting yay 190 voting nay the
tabling motion
fails question is now on the adoption
the amendment it is a division vote the
question now is the
the adoption of the amendment this is
going to be a division vote so members
seats represent isqu representative H
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
vote
repr
time
okay the motion before us is ought to
pass on the amendment
94h this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
while members presid have an opportunity
vote 191 voting yay 183 voting aay the
amendment is adopted now on otpa now
we're on
otpa and a division vote has been
requested so everybody should be in
their
seats so the motion before us
is a to pass as amended G recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that there was no
valid testimony in support of the
original bill it was really testimony
that was completely untethered from
reality and was an insult to our entire
system of election Administration
ranging from the secretary of State down
to our hardworking local moderators and
clerks and if I also know that the face
saving amendment to this bill also
provides an unsatisfactory solution to
an improbable Nyon impossible situation
that has never occurred in New Hampshire
and that frankly it never could occur
and if I know that this
unsatisfactory imaginary situation is
amazingly enough already addressed in
statute rendering this bill both
redundant and unnecessary but I now
press the red button to overturn the OTP
so that a more appropriate motion may be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative katar Pro
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that part two article 32 of
our constitution requires a fair record
of votes and if I know that this bill
allows for a recount when it is
mathematically impossible that either
there was a fair record of the votes or
that only qualified voters voted and if
I know that I want to ensure that we
have a recount remedy available if and
when it is needed would I now press the
green
button motion before is saw to pass as
amended on House Bill
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent all members present have an
opportunity to vote how will tend to
state to the
vote 191 voting a 183 voting aay
committee report is
adopted
right represent
pass in the amendment questions on the
amendment no debate or anything
the the committee on Election law to
which is referred HB 1364 relative to
intimidation of election officers
improper influence over the electoral
process and tampering with an electronic
ballot counting devices comes to us
without recommendation representative
Mirad moves OD to pass and offers
Amendment
08908 printed on house record hand on
pages 47 to
48 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted the motion is now ought to
pass as amended for what reason does a
member rise Mr Speaker I move indefinite
postpone on HB
1364 representative Sweeney moves that
house bill 1364 be indefinitely
postponed and request a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
you
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill
1364 representative Barry is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our election workers are
some of the hardest working often
volunteer uh people that we have in our
community and Mr Speaker if I know that
any actions against them are horrible
and Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
while very well-intentioned has First
Amendment issues that were not addressed
would I now press the green button to
support the indefinite postponement
motion representative Mir has recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would give the
attorney general and law enforcement the
powers they need to protect election
workers
and if I'm not afraid to hear this bill
debated on its merits would I press the
debate the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1364
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
represent
maral
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 184 in the
postponed the committee on Election law
which is referred House Bill 1369
relative to verification of voter roles
every four years comes to us without
recommendation representative warry
moves ought to pass this will be a
seats represent restive Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
vote
the question is the motion about to pass
on House Bill 1369 representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and fellow
Representatives if I know that more
frequent voter roll purges leads to more
disenfranchised voters and that the
Secretary of State suggested doing a
six-year Purge instead of a 4-year and
if I know that 30-day notices of removal
from the checklist are not always
received uh by voters and if I know that
New Hampshire could join a shared
database like Eric to update voter roles
that could handle this issue better then
I would press the red button so a better
motion could be made thank
you representative where is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues if I know that the 2021 voter
verification effort removed 21% of the
voter roles quarter of a million voters
and if I know that the voter roles from
2020 were unduly inflated and were
inadequately maintained during that
10-year interval between 2011 and 2021
and if I know that a 4-year voter
verification interval would prompt a
more diligent and adequate maintenance
of the checklist and if I know that the
proposed look back period would capture
the largest number of active voters by
reviewing back through the last
presidential election would I now press
the green button in support of HB
the questions on the motion about to
pass and House Bill 1369 and this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
seconds
represent
sopus have all members PR had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 191 in the affirmative 181 and the
adopted we're going straight to a
division vote so don't wander too far
the majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred out
spill 1370 FN an act relative to durable
and Cher proof containers for preserving
ballots having considered the same
report the same with the rec
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative wber R wary for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with a following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Heidi Kramer for the minority of the
committee this will be a division vote
seats
clear
the question is a motion about to pass
and House Bill 1370 and this is a
division
vote representative Hammer is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the Secretary of State's office
provides trainings on how to seal up a
box of ballots and if I know that I've
been sealing ballots boxes since 20 2014
without an incident and if I know that
recyclable cardboard boxes are Earth
friendly would I now press the red
button to oppose this autop pass motion
so that another motion may be brought
forward thank
you representative War's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker my fellow Representatives if I
know that by law we must meet the
federal and state requirements for the
retention of B ballots in related
election records and if I know that the
cast ballots must be securely stored and
maintained for any recounts or audits
that need to be performed and if I know
that flimsy overused and too often
reused cardboard boxes are sometimes not
sufficiently durable and stackable no
matter how much packing tape or duct
tape is used and if I know that durable
ergonomically friendly and ecologically
friendly storage boxes might not only
save the backs of our election workers
but would also save some trees would I
now press the green button for ought to
1370 the questions on the motion of
ought to pass and House Bill 1370 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
press the green button oppos press the
seconds
you representa Ean
Kelly have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 2 54 in
the affirmative 120 and the negative the
motion's
adopted the committee on Election law to
which is referred House Bill 1557 FN
requiring the secretary of state to
enter into a membership agreement with
the electronic registration information
Center comes to us without
recommendation representative Brennan
moves a to
[Music]
pass for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I move indefinite
postpone on HB
1557 represent Sweeney moves that we
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1557
and requested a roll call vote is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
to
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill 1557 representative
Barry is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry yes thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that the electronic
registration information center or more
Cally known as Eric is a grow violation
of New Hampshire State C New Hampshire
State Constitution Article 2B the right
to privacy the right to private
information and I also know Mr Mr
Speaker that the Eric system requires
the transmission of New Hampshire data
including the last four digits of a
social security number a driver's
license number a birth date the full
name the address and the mailing address
what I now press the green button to
oppose to support excuse me to support
the the indefinite postp pment motion
and protect our right to
privacy representative Brennan's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that opponents of Eric have fallen
victim to political
hyperparasite Staters overwhelmingly
support passing this bill as
demonstrated in New Hampshire specific
polling hundreds of online signin and
inperson
testimony and if I know that this is an
election Integrity Bill where we share
concerns about the 10-year voter purges
have an
opportunity to regularly improve our
voter
checklists and we have an opportunity to
hear this bill in full and have a proper
debate about it would I now press the
red
button the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1557
this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
for
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 185 in the
postponed
the committee on Election law to which
is referred House Bill 1569 FN relative
to eliminating voter identification
exceptions comes to us without
recommendation representative Barry
moves ought to
pass representative Howard is recognized
motion thank you Mr Speaker and
honorable
Representatives this bill does two major
things it A establishes A system that
would allow any person to challenge
another voter and thus disenfranchise
them and B eradicates not just the ID
and domicile affidavits but all
affidavits associated with
voting this would create a new voter
challenge system that would allow anyone
to challenge voters and provides the
moderator with the sole discretion to
prevent somebody from voting the
challenge process allows anyone with a
hypothetical grievance to stop a fellow
voter from casting a ballot there is no
meaningful due
process uh for the potential voters
whose most important right is being
taken away while a challenged voter has
the right to dispute the challenge at
one of 11 New Hampshire Superior Courts
it would be highly unlike
if a voter is able to exercise that
right because for example if challenged
uh an individual who lives in Pittsburgh
would have to travel an hour to The
Cordon
Lancaster if an individual showed up to
vote after at 5:00 P p.m. or after it's
basically not worth it it is
unreasonable to require challenge voters
to go through all of this just to prove
their own
eligibility
ironically the challenge system relies
on an
affidavit uh on on the Affidavit of the
Challenger it would it requires the
Challenger to sign an affidavit to
prevent another person from voting but
the potential voter is not allowed to
sign an affidavit to refute the
Challenger someone could just walk into
a polling location sign a few papers and
take away your right to vote not making
it more difficult to register and
depriving someone
uh of the right to vote based on
allegations not backed by evidence is
not the New Hampshire way secondly the
eradication of all affidavits will
disenfranchise many New Hampshire
citizens Republicans Democrats and
independents currently when registering
to vote voters are asked to provide
proof of identity age domicile and
citizenship if they are registering and
lack documentation for any of those they
are able to sign an affidavit then
register and cast a ballot when voters
are signing a voting affidavit they
swear under the oath to its veracity if
false they face a fine of up to $5,000
in a year in
jail the documents required by this
legislation are expensive and take a
lengthy time to procure passports take
about 9 weeks and and cost about
$130 birth certificates have different
costs from state to state uh and can
take weeks to obtain and can be
difficult for many people who are unsure
about the state that they were born in
while naturalization papers can cost
well over $500 and take months to obtain
college students houseless people
seniors new Americans and Military
members uh will be adversely affected by
this bill if passed this would violate
the federal requirement for provisional
voting that was introduced in section
302 of the help America vote act by
failing to fulfill the required
provisional
options finally this bill is
unconstitutional in similar to
legislation uh from Kansas that was
struck down in the 10th Circuit Court of
Appeals in 2020 New Hampshire has
already gone through an expensive
lawsuit uh when it comes to voting
rights and this would immediately cost
taxpayers uh and your constituents a
bill that would rival the taxpayer what
the taxpayers paid for s sp3 or nearly
$4 million in legal fees the governor
and Secretary of State have both
reassured us that our elections are free
and fair with no signs of widespread
voter
fraud and the Attorney General closed 18
investigations after the 2020 election
uh with the result of no criminal or
civil proceedings instances of voter
fraud in New Hampshire are negligible
and a UNH survey showed that 92% of New
Hampshire voters have confidence in the
outcome of the 2022 election yet this
bill upends our same day
registration system uh by eliminating
the affidavit system that has worked
well for decades if you believe this
bill would disenfranchise voters
threatened take uh their right to vote
away leave taxpayers with a hefty bill
and if passed in uh into law before
would be enacted before the 2024
election then I would vote no on the
motion of ought to pass so a more
appropriate one could be made and Mr
you representative where is recognized
to speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues thank you for your time and
attention I will be brief Less Than 3
minutes over two decades ago in the fall
of 2000 the forensics crime drama CSI
crime Scene Investigation premiered it
was a captivating series and the opening
theme of that great TV show asked an
important question who are you do do do
do and just a few days ago in many towns
throughout New Hampshire in the context
of voting that same question was
repeatedly asked throughout the granite
state who are you our bill for
consideration clarifies those four
qualifications for voting citizenship
age domicile and identity and once a
person is registered to vote in the
great state of New Hampshire they need
only answer that one question who are
you the bill also makes provision for
General voter registration registering
at the polling place and election day
registration as well now you may ask
what would a potential voter do if they
were lacking a valid photo
identification this bill addresses that
situation the supervisor of the
checklist can attempt to establish that
that voter meets the New Hampshire's
voting
criteria and if that is problematic the
bill provides for an immediate remedy
through the superior court but let's
return to the question of the moment may
I gently remind my dear colleagues that
many many activities require
identification
when you board an airplane they ask who
are
you when you open a bank account or cash
a check they ask who are you when you
request or use a credit card they ought
to be asking who are you when you cross
a northern border that at least they ask
who are you when you apply for a
business license when you secure
employment when you serve on jury duty
when you purchase real estate when you
purchase a car when you rent a car or a
house or a domicile when you purchase a
firearm they ask who are you when you go
to the doctor's office when you purchase
alcoholic products when you pick up a
prescription all these common life
activities require some proof of of
identity to answer who are
you this Common Sense Bill simply ask
voters to do what they have already done
in so many other places answer the
question who are you honorable
colleagues I humbly ask that you do do
do do support this
speaker now I have a song by The Who
pal the question is on the motion about
to pass an House Bill 1569
representative H request a roll call
seconded doesn't look sufficiently
seconded this will be a division vote
requested
by who asked me for a division vote
representative Howard asked for division
vote
seats
e
ter
the questions on the motion of a to pass
in House Bill
1569 representative Lane is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker even with
my hearing aids I'm not able to hear
very very well so if I know that passing
this bill will re will create upheaval
in our fall elections because it will go
into effect immediately before our
primaries and it is overturning our
entire way that we hold elections and if
I know that this bill is
unconstitutional and will spawn
expensive
litigation and if I know that this bill
will take away our most important right
the right to vote from thousands of New
Hampshire citizens then would I press
the red button to oppose
disenfranchising those thousands of
Voters based on no evidence of
widespread fraud under our current
system thank
you representative Barry's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I agree Mr Speaker that this
bill will will cause upheaval of joy as
New Hampshire finally joins the rest of
the country in having voter ID a policy
that Mr
Speaker I believe over 70% of granted
stator support including 50% of
registered Democrats Mr Speaker if I
know that this weekend is St Patrick's
Day would I look down think about this
button the questions on the motion about
to pass anoun Bill 1569 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 185 and the
adopted four what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker having voting on the
prevailing side of HB 1369 I move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote
now representative Sweeney moves
reconsideration
1369 this will be a division vote
seats
all right members should be in their
seats the question is whether to
reconsider House Bill 1369 n this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 185 and
the affirmative 189 and negative
reconsideration
fails welcome back what reason does the
member rise thank you Mr Speaker having
voting on the prevailing side of HB
1569 I move reconsideration and urge the
body to vote
no
1569 representative Sweeney moves
1569 division this will be a division
seats
e
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill 1569 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
B
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 186 in the affirmative 188 in the
negative reconsideration
do for what reason does a member rise to
make a
motion a motion
okay being on the prevailing side of HB
1029 I'd like to reconsider
that okay representative sellers moves
1029 was acting on last
week was last
okay serve notice last Friday this is
from last
week House Bill 1029 relative to
exempting certain persons from requiring
a New Hampshire Landing license if such
purpose persons are not Landing for the
purpose of the sale of the lobster or
crab they have
caught so he's recognized to speak to
his motion you are recognized to speak
to your
motion yes Mr speaker thank you very
much
I just want to say that uh when I voted
last week I did actually make a mistake
first time in my life believe it or not
and I'd hope you consider re uh
recognized no I only want
to yes just do representative Derby
requests a division vote members take
your
the
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill 1029 representative spel is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that some people were unaware of the
fact that uh the the Atlantic commission
actually does not mandate the reporting
of data but it's just a suggestion and
that the landing license actually has no
tie into the way that that data is
collected by fishing game that the data
is actually voluntarily submitted and
can still be voluntarily submitted if we
don't charge people $50 for bringing the
lobsters or crabs to shore on a boat and
if I further know that if somebody walks
out from Shore to get crab and then
walks back they don't have to pay the
$50 but if they do so from a boat they
do have to pay $50 and if I further know
that if somebody does it on Route 93 and
comes up they don't have to pay the $50
but if they come in on a boat they have
to do
$50 would I now press green to allow
reconsideration so that several members
who did not know this information could
now make the correct choice and try to
send this bill over to the other body
where another public hearing could flesh
out all of the
complications representative Darby's
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
extend Mr Speaker if if I knew that we
extensively debated this last week and
it was found inexpedient to legislate on
a bipartisan vote and if I knew that
this so-called new information was not
presented not questioned um and not
raised during public hearings and that
if it were to be presented it if new
information were to come forward it
should come through a public hearing
where this body can discuss it and if I
knew that neither fishing uh New
Hampshire fishing game who manages the
Val valuable up fishery nor New
Hampshire loberman including the Yankee
Fisherman's Cooperative both who both
oppose this bill want this um vote
reconsidered and Mr Speaker if I knew
that we have over 40 bills to debate and
vote on today and we don't need
additional rounds of speeches and votes
to prolong the day would I support New
Hampshire lobsters New Hampshire lobster
fishermen and push the red button to
oppose reconsider this reconsideration
motion thank
you questions rather to reconsider House
Bill 1029 this a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppos
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 176 in the affirmative 193 in the
the committee on executive departments
and administration which was referred
House Bill 1252 an act relative to
establishing a committee to study the
needs of Native Americans in New
Hampshire having inste of the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Jack Gro groa for the
committee the questions on the committee
report about to pass you ready for the
question all those in favor say I all
those oppos n the I have it and the
adopted the majority of the committee on
finance to which was referred Senate
Bill
395 an act relative to to establishing
the position of assistant commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture markets
and food having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Peter Lehman for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
J.R Hull for the minority of the
committee representative paten is
report
thank you honorable members I rise today
to speak against the a to pass for SP
395 for several reasons all of New
Hampshire citizens have been having to
work extra hard in these difficult times
when everything costs more I am sure
many of us in here and our constituents
would like to have an assistant to help
them in their daily work unfortunately
that is not possible or practical
as you may or may not know the
Department of Agriculture is ending the
organic program in April due to staffing
issues and the high cost to run the
program that should free up some of the
burden the agency had with a couple of
their staff that were handling the
program I strongly believe the agency
Actually All State agencies should be
working feverishly to tighten up their
operations especially to eliminate waste
redundancy and fine cost savings but
moreover to work more efficiently our
New Hampshire families are doing this
every day and we need to demand the same
from our government we all know how
bloated government agencies have become
let's support working smarter not harder
and not further burdening the New
Hampshire taxpayer please vote red on
the ought to pass so another motion can
be made and Mr Speaker I ask for a
division vote
the questions the committee report about
to pass on Senate Bill 395 this is a
seats
e
the question is a committee report about
to pass on Senate Bill 395
representative Hull is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker I know that this is a Senate
bill that's being pushed through through
pretty
quickly while we're busy dealing with
house bills if I know that this is on a
rocket docket of some type because the
position was accounted for in hb2 LA or
hb1 last year financially but not in
hb2 but if I know the position creates a
third senior management position in the
department of a with a minimum salary of
$887,000 and a potential salary of
$121,000 resulting in a half a million
dollar cost potentially including
benefits over the next three years for
this department if I know that the
current budget for this department is
just over $2.8 million and has 51
positions and that we don't need yet one
more Senior Management person would I
vote no on the a to pass motion so
another motion could be brought up
representative lean's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this position was in
fact in the budget as far as a budget
line
item however through no oversight of the
finance committee the language
supporting that position was not
included and if I know after uh a
thorough review by the finance committee
we voted 20 to two to support this
wouldn't I press the green button Mr
Speaker
the question is the committee report of
about to pass on Senate Bill 395 and
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
you
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote 213 and
the affirmative 136 and the negative the
adopted
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 1231 an
act permitting qualifying patients and
designated caregivers to cultivate
cannabis for therapeutic use having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Joe
Shapiro for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative David Nagel for the
minority the amendment is
0887 H printed on house record CH on
page 44 the questions on the amendment
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the amendment's adopted
no debate the question now is on the
motion of ought to pass are representers
requested R yeah representative Grangers
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
it
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 1231 and this is a roll
call vote if you are in favor press the
green button if you're opposed press the
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
294 in the affirmative 66 in a negative
adopted the committee on legislative
Administration which is referred house
resolution 25 an act resolving to return
to the historical intent of the express
trust in denture the New Hampshire
Constitution specifically part one
Article 2 and part 2 article 32 having
considered the same report the same same
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative Nicki mcarter for the
committee the questions on the report of
interim study are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no the eyes have it and
adopted the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
which was referred House Bill 1326 FN an
act relative to notification processes
for large ground water withdrawal
applications having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
will Derby from the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Andrew Rulo for the minority of the
committee the question is on the
majority committee report of an
expedient to legislate be ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
report's
adopted
am committee on state and federal
relations Veterans Affairs to which is
referred House Bill 1156 relative to
public health safety and state
sovereignty comes without recommendation
representative Tom Manion moves ought to
pass offers floor Amendment 058 2H
printed in house record 10 page 43- 44
the question is on the amendment all
[Music]
n a division has been
purposes
[Applause]
all right the motion before us is a
division vote on the amendment which was
unclear who won so if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you press press the red button
seconds
[Music]
represent
kofalt
e
okay all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
vote 158 voting a 173 voting nay the
amendment
fails now we're back to ought to
pass on House Bill 1156 chair recognizes
represent
filio
Mr Speaker I rise in opposition to HP
1156 and urge my colleagues to likewise
oppose this OTP motion my motion my
opposition stems from three points
the bill solves to so seeks to solve an
improbable
problem the bill goes too far in
addressing a narrow grievance and
finally the bill violates our most
sacred Free Speech rights first the bill
Sol seeks to solve an improbable
problem the bill seeks to ensure the
World Health Organization shall have no
jurisdiction in New Hampshire and a loss
of sovereignty is a natural
concern we do things well here in the
granite state but how would this loss of
sovereignty
occur in committee we heard testimony
about the pandemic prevention
preparedness and response Accord a World
Health Organization agreement regarding
pandemic prevention and
response the treaty's terms explicitly
addressed State sovereignty saying
states have in accordance with the
charter of the United Nations and the
general principles of international law
The Sovereign right to legislate and
Implement legislation in pursuance of
their health
policies that level of production might
be unconvincing and if so recall that
2third of the federal Senate must give
advice and consent before a treaty's
ratification and let's be real 2/3 of
the federal Senate is unlikely to agree
to their coffee order before they're
likely to agree to International
pandemic response treaty and finally
even if the implausible happens and the
federal Senate does give advice and
consent to something treaties are rarely
self- enforcing that is they require
further enacting legislation to put them
into practice that would require further
congressional action from a body that
often moves at glacial
Pace finally our state constitution at
article 7
protects our state sovereignty in all
areas not already explicitly delegated
to
Congress and while there's complex
constitutional arguments to be had here
were Congress to enact legislation
abrogating individual State sovereignty
it's hard to see that surviving any type
of judicial
scrutiny all this to say World Health
Organization officers in Kean or lonia
or Portsmouth or elsewhere won't be
happening state in US law doesn't
provide a means for it thus this bill
while while intention May Chase
windmills my second point of opposition
is that the bill goes too far in
addressing a narrow grievance the bill
focuses on the World Health Organization
or alternatively the Centers for Disease
Control and perhaps that's natural given
our recent shared experience in the
World Health Organization in CDC being
in headlines of we all grappled with an
unprecedented Global
pandemic the World Health Organization
and CDC recommendations about Co
undoubtedly struck some as unnecessary
and
excessive others may have found them as
coming up short but what's important is
the World Health Organization and cdc's
work extends well beyond pandemic
preparedness the World Health
Organization recommends that all those
at high risk for HIV consider regular
testing and consider pre-exposure
prophylaxis the World Health
Organization recommends early initiation
of breastfeeding and says breastfeeding
is a vital part of infant nutrition and
the World Health Organization recommends
raw Mercury be limited to less than one
microgram per liter of fresh water of
course this list could go on and on as
World Health Organization and CDC
recommendations touch upon every area of
our health but suffice it to say that
while the who may eror it also does good
its recommendations ought be evaluated
on their individual merits and analyzed
according to good reason that may
sometimes lead to different conclusions
among reasonable and well-intentioned
people and that's
okay and that recognition of difference
of opinion leads to my final point in
opposition the bill of friends Free
Speech the Bill's terms State any
requirements mandates or instructions
from the World Health Organization shall
not be used in the state to justify any
mask vaccine or medical testing
requirements thus the bill seeks to
eliminate from public debate and
consideration a Viewpoint and ideas
which some may find to be offensive or
wrong as the bill forbids World Health
Organization recommendations
from being used to justify Health
requirements now imagine the situation
this creates if a local school board
member mentions the World Health
Organization when debating a proposal
that board member has probably done
something wrong they've likely put the
proposal in the crosshairs of litigation
merely because a Viewpoint was expressed
or if a city council passes a measure
and the minutes reflect a counselor
opined on World Health organiz ation
recommendations that council's ordinance
is in Peril because a counselor
expressed an opinion based on available
data recall that article 222 of our
state constitution says that free speech
in Liberty of the press are essential to
the security and freedom in a state they
ought therefore to be inviolably
preserved that's a huge undertaking and
and often a difficult
one indeed the late Supreme Court
Justice Louis brandise a Titan of free
speech Juris Prudence said the cure to
speech is more speech not enforced
silence as a state and as a nation we
don't suppress ideas we don't like we
don't remove them from public debate and
consideration simply because we disagree
or find them
offensive we do it differently we speak
up we out debate we plead persuade and
protest and if we lose we might even try
again but we don't
silence so here rather than whole scale
stopping the school board member or
local councilmen from citing the World
Health Organization the notion of free
speech Demands a different outcome
defeat those ideas at the
lecturn convince others to your side and
may the best ideas
win and ultimately that's the hard
painful work of free speech because it
doesn't ask us to protect the ideas with
which we agree that's the easy part
rather Free Speech asks us to protect
the ideas we loath those that rile us to
to our core because
ultimately those ideas have value too in
a Marketplace of
ideas voler once said as paraphrased by
one of our esteemed colleagues earlier
today I may not agree with what you say
but I will defend to the death your
right to say it it remains true now
whether hundreds of minutes or hundreds
of years
later and thus Mr Mr Speaker I urge the
body to press the red button on this OTP
motion because the bill addresses an
improbable
problem the bill goes too far in
addressing a narrow
grievance and because the bill tramples
on the essence of free speech the
protection of the ideas we hate May the
cacophony of debate live on and may we
speech
beler thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is an important one to
me this bill foremost acts to nullify
the authority of the World Health
Organization within the borders of the
state in early Co times is now known
that extremely aggressive ventilator
treatments for ill patients resulted in
significant amounts of unnecessary
morbidity immortality those guidelines
killed Americans where did they come
from they came from the
who who then ran and still runs the
who a gentleman who hails from Ethiopia
a man who is not and never has been a
healthc care professional though he has
been credibly accused of covering up
pandemics and outbreaks in his own home
nation before running the wh this
gentleman from Ethiopia was a member a
ranking member of the Communist Party in
his home country the Tigra people's
Liberation Front officially recognized
as a terrorist organization by the
United States of America how did he get
this job the lobbying of the Chinese
Communist party at the United Nations
placed this gentleman in that
position that's the same Chinese
Communist Party responsible for the
creation and the release
accidental or otherwise of the co virus
from the Wuhan military
laboratory early in covid the Chinese
government ran a series of online
disinformation and psychological warfare
operations involving people dropping
dead in the streets lockdown procedures
including the welding of apartment doors
shut and other Draconian measures China
developed the lockdown model and went to
Great Lengths to scare the the world the
Western world into adopting it to make
economies now we credibly Face a threat
as an existing treaty is up for
modification an existing treaty who here
trusts that a treaty as modified will
require the same full approval process
by the House and Senate as a normal
treaty and they will not attempt to
enforce this on us without going through
that process again this treaty would
effectively put the who in charge
directly of New Hampshire Health policy
they could demand we lock down our
economy again and guess why it's not
just pandemics it's not just viruses
here's a couple other things that the
World Health Organization believes are
threats that might require
lockdown climate change and racism
according to them those are public
health threats that could qualify for
economic
lockdowns lastly if the who happens to
get something right there's nothing that
would prevent our health professionals
our Public Health people in this state
from doing that from doing the right
thing it only says we cannot use
directly who guidelines to justify our
own actions we can still do it if it's
the right thing we just have to point to
the
science
please vote Yes by pressing the green
button and Mr Speaker I would request a
roll
call for what reason member
rise having voted on the prevailing side
of the amendment for this bill I ask
reconsideration and ask the members to
push
green the motion be yes the Amendments
the the motion before us is
amendment a division has been requested
seats
e
the motion the motion be Forest is
reconsideration on the amendment to
House Bill
1156 this is going to be a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
seconds
represent
Smith
OB
spear
represent all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
to the
vote
178 voting yay 193 voting nay the
reconsideration fails we're now back to
the original motion of a to
pass representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
vote
for
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1156 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Massa
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill prohibits the
enforcing of any guidance or
recommendation from the World Health
Organization regarding a
pandemic if I also know that research
shows that the
wh encourages its members to take steps
to introduce Implement and support their
suggestions but no control over a
sovereign nation's Health Care policy
or
programs and finally Mr Speaker if I
know this bill is unnecessary because it
is entirely a matter for a Sovereign
Nation to choose what to do with any wh
information would you now join me in
pressing the red button so another
motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes representative
Tom Manion for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr speaker if I know that the
World Health Organization has proposed
sweeping changes to an existing
International Health treaty to be voted
on in May and if I know these changes
include broadening Authority
surveillance mandatory monetary
contributions and more and finally if I
believe that an extra National
Organization directed by the Chinese
Communist Party should have no say in
how New Hampshire manages Health then I
would press the green button to support
1156 the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
1156 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
while members present and an opportunity
vote 181 voting yay 190 voting nay you
ought to pass motion fails represent
M Mr representative massam massam moves
inexpedient to
legislate Mr Speaker I would move
indefinite
postponement it's a higher motion
postp Senate Weber moves in TM a
postponement on House Bill 1156
for what reason member rise for a motion
of higher
priority St motion higher priority
motion table
on
close it
um did you not close it out
or
table there we
go the motion before usion V the motion
before us is to table house bill
1156 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
representative
partial okay all members present had an
opportunity to vote also ATT the state
vote 186 voting aay 185 voting a 11 56
is laid on the table chair did not vote
vote
cyber committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred hr23 calling upon New
Hampshire Congressional Delegation to
support a national universal health
insurance program reprentative cybert
moves ought to pass chair recognizes
representative
morett thank you Mr
Speaker to be sure our American Health
Care System needs improvements we spend
far too much per capita than any other
country and there's certainly policies
and efficiencies that we need to look at
there are certainly gaps in coverage we
know that we can do better but is
single-payer national health insurance
the best way to go just look at the
countries that have that that have gone
there some have had experiences better
than others but all too often they end
up with lower Quality Health Care
especially if Health Care Providers
receive inadequate
reimbursement also under such systems
people lose their choices choices they
lose choice
when they go to Single Payer in these
other countries and a lack of
competition and a lack of choice lessens
the pressures on
providers to perform or to
innovate rationing is Common Place in
many of these countries we just have to
look where this has been tried and what
ha what's happened time and time
again we've all heard the horror stories
and they're real people who died in
these other countries waiting for for
treatment because they couldn't get
scheduled tellingly countless people
from other countries with national
health insurance come to America they
come here from these other countries
that have National Insurance and they
they're in line they can't get help for
important treatments they come
here and with our current open
borders we have millions of people
busting in here and overwhelming what we
current currently have in terms of
emergency room treatment and yet many of
the proponents of national health
insurance want to include undocumented
migrants in this plan that is a sure way
to overwhelm what's already a system
that's that's stressed so poll after
poll shows a majority of Americans to be
satisfied with the plans they have in
place I am and probably most of you are
so why do we want to change that
drastically like I said the the things
need attention but we need to revamp we
don't need to replace our current
Speaker chair recognized representative
L
montine thank you Mr
Speaker and good afternoon my fellow
members of the house I rise in support
of hr20 three calling on our federal
delegation to support a national
universal health insurance
program our complicated wasteful health
insurance system is a
catastrophe we spend more on health care
per capita than any country on Earth and
have the worst Health
outcomes it's true what is said that
people come from all over the world to
access American Health Care but wealthy
people paying cash for the best doctors
in the world is not the same thing as
people coming here to buy Private health
insurance they
don't opponents of the resolution state
that many citizens are happy with their
current
Arrangements no one testified at the
hearing that they love their private
health insurance on the contrary we
heard many stories of necessary Health
Care being denied and being too
expensive two members of the committee
who said they were happy with their
health
insurance actually have national
government run Single Payer Health
insurance that would be TR care and
Medicare yes people on those plans are
it why with Single Payer you can go to
any provider you want private public or
nonprofit people ask how can we afford a
national health insurance program but
the real question is how can we afford
not to have one the Crux of the matter
is that is that we have two separate
risk pools for health insurance one is
the low-risk pool the healthy working
adult population and their children few
of whom have any major medical problems
or
expenses the other is the high risk pool
who's in that pool everyone with a
disability they're automatically on
Medicare any child with a major medical
problem automatically on the chip
program regardless of their income level
all the poor they're on
Medicaid and most importantly the
elderly they're on Medicare Who as a
group have the highest health costs and
the highest prescription drug cost of
any other
group so the private sector
has the luxury of ensuring the low-risk
pool at and making huge profits at it
but the government is tasked with
ensuring the high-risk
pool most of us are going to pay Private
health insurance for 50 years our entire
working lives we going to pay into that
year after year and not one penny of
that money goes into the pool to take
care of us when we're old we hit 65 and
we're dropped like a hot potato and have
to go on Medicare so I ask you how is
this
sustainable how can the government
possibly keep that up you want to cut
national debt have national health
insurance and we all increase our
contribution from the 2 to 3% We already
pay to
5% that would be much less expensive for
you and your employer who are now paying
12 to 20% of every salary into Private
health
insurance if we combined risk pools like
every other country in the world we
could afford to provide long-term care
insurance for the elderly who need it as
it is now ordinary working and middle
class people who have the misfortune of
prolonged age related disability or
dementia are forced to spend their
entire life savings sell their homes
leave nothing for their children just to
pay for their long-term
care and that is because we have allowed
private insurance companies to profit
from uring them their entire working
lives and contribute nothing for their
care when they're old a national health
insurance uh plan would allow us to have
long-term care for our seniors and we
would no longer need Medicare
supplements or the the awful Advantage
Plans we need to do it and it must be
done at the federal level which is why
this is a health of house
resolution aside from the elderly what's
in it for young people personal freedom
is one of the reasons I am in favor of a
national health insurance plan you could
pursue the job you love not just the job
that has benefits you could start a
small business without wor woring how
you going to have health insurance for
yourself let alone your
employees Single Payer will easily
easily provide insurance for Gig workers
who are often the ones who have no
insurance and instead of bargaining over
Health Plans Union unions can focus on
better wages working conditions and
retirement
plans Single Payer would also benefit
manufacturers who are trying to compete
with companies and other other countries
in fact almost every other country in
the world where companies do not have to
pay for insurance for their employees it
would make us more competitive in the
global
economy but let's be clear we do not
have a free market in health insurance
we don't have choice if you get coverage
through your job your employer picks a
plan you don't have any say about it and
if you buy it through the marketplace
you really only have one option
and providers are severely restricted by
networks you can't choose which doctor
you go to your insurance plan chooses
that for
you and also why isn't Medicaid
expansion enough why do we need Single
Payer I don't like the Medicaid Program
and don't misunderstand me I would never
vote to take it away from anyone until
we have another option but Medicaid
entails enormous administrative C costs
to screen for income and you have to
keep doing it over and over again it's
also tedious to apply for it and that's
a barrier to
participation and it's a literal barrier
to access because many doctors simply
won't accept Medicaid
patients and it's a disincentive to work
or an incentive to work under the table
because if you start to make a little
more money you're going to lose your
insurance
if we opened up Medicare for all for
example we could do away with Medicaid
Al together and save a lot of
money Medicare and tri care are national
government run single-payer Health Care
Systems and they work very
well they are more efficient than other
private than private insurance companies
% most importantly it will allow us to
prioritize reimbursement for Primary
Care which the private insurance Market
does not do which is why we have a
crisis of primary care in this
country my husband's doctor retired last
year it took him four months to find a
doctor that was even accepting new
patients for Primary Care and the first
appointment he get he could get is still
away so the other important thing about
a national
insurance program it was it would mean
Managed Care could be about providing
best medical practices and not just
maximizing shareholder
profits this is not socialized medicine
it is just the insurance you can still
go to whatever doctor you want
to it will cost the state of New
Hampshire
nothing and as for illegal immigrants if
you don't have a Social Security card
you wouldn't get a national insurance
card
either so I urge you all to vote oh or
to pass on this resolution and I ask for
vote
for what member does it reason a member
rise Mr Speaker I move indefinite
postponement on
vote sen Sweeney moves indefinite
h23 and ask for a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
seats
e
C
the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on
hr23 this is going to be a roll call
vote if if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
button
okay chair recognizes representative for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that most Granite Staters
would be unable to afford or even
severely set back by needing to pay
nearly
$7,000 or more a year to their
employer's choice of high deductible
medical plan in addition to already
paying co-pays and premiums and if I
know under our current system year after
year these same Granite Staters have
seen an increase in cost while at the
very same time seeing a decrease in
benefit coverage and if I also know that
we as a country are fully capable of
figuring out a unique system that works
for us regardless of what other
countries have already done and finally
Mr Speaker if I know that preventative
health care has been shown to not only
lengthen lives but also decrease health
care costs over time would I press the
red button to overturn this indefinite
postponement motion and allow another
motion to be made so that hopefully New
Hampshire can send a strongly worded
message to our federal government that
our state expects a solution to be found
thank
you chair recognized representative Lin
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I know that in other
countries with national health insurance
that folks have ended up receiving lower
Quality Health Care when providers
receive inadequate reimbursements for
their costs and if I know that the folks
from such countries often end up
traveling to America for health care and
if I know that a majority of Americans
are satisfied with their current health
care plans and I know that I am a doctor
who has spent many times many years
excuse me dealing with healthc care
administrations that I would press the
green button to indefinitely postpone
thank you motion before us is indefinite
postponement on hr23 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote member needs to be in their
seats 192 voting yay 179 voting nay
hr23 for what reason do member
rise I move to put the debate in the
permanent record I'm sorry can we put
the debate in the permanent record
please debate in the permanent record
you
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred hr26 urging Congress to adopt
constitutional amendment to distinguish
between corporate and individual rights
comes without recommendation Senator
Massa Miller moves ought to pass for
what reason does a member rise thank you
Mr Speaker I move indefinite postpone on
hr26 and I ask for a roll call
vote the motion before us is in definite
postponement on hr26 Senator Sweeney has
asked for a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
vote
the motion before his in dep
postponement on HR 26 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
Catherine all members presid had an
opportunity to vote also will take
extend it to
vote
194 voting a 179 voting a hr26 is
indefinitely
postponed committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred HR
27 an act calling for policy makers
locally and nationally to fully consider
all relevant information and factors
pertaining to climate change before
pursuing courses of action that could
adversely affect any economy or
environment consider the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass sen Michael Moffett
for the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Sebert
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
measure is not just about climate change
It ultimately seeks to undermine how we
currently conduct everyday business here
at the State House the principle of
hearing both sides of an issue before
weighing the decision is essential in
ensuring the fairness of the
decision-making process this principle
embodies the core values of democracy
transparency and Justice which we hold
dear in this legislature we listen to
and consider multiple perspectives On
Any Given issue and allow stakeholders
to present their arguments and evidence
in parliamentary proceedings the
practice of hearing both sides of an
issue before weighing a decision
reinforces the Integrity of our
deliberative process and enhances the
legitimacy of our outcomes please join
me and voting no on the ought to pass
motion so another motion can be made
thank
MAF thank Mr speaker there are five
giant paintings up here in this H we all
look at you see uh Webster Pierce
Washington Lincoln but who's this other
guy well a lot of you may not know
that's Senator John P hail he's an
abolitionist US senator who served
during the Civil War uh but many many of
you may not know is that his daughter
Lucy uh was engaged to one of the most
famous actors of the time during the
Civil War uh hail's that guy's future
son-in-law was a guy named John wils
Booth yeah the same guy who assassinated
that guy Abraham Lincoln Booth had
Lucy's picture near his heart when he
was shot dead in 1865 Lucy quickly moved
from New Hampshire to Europe so what
what does this little history lesson
have to do with climate change the point
is that some information some history
some facts can be uncomfortable uh
inconvenient to acknowledge such as the
relationship between Lucy hail and John
wils Booth and similarly there's a lack
of uh climate information total climate
information history and facts uh that
need to be better presented many years
ago as a un freshman I took a a course
in this and I was scared to death and
yet I went back and found the book The
Textbook that I was giv way back then
and in the predictions and the Doomsday
scenarios uh didn't come true this is in
the 70s so those of us who make laws or
pressured by activists to take climate
Action Now climate action now or else
we're doomed now some states have law
have already passed laws to uh
California is you can't you can't drive
a gas powered vehicle there past the
date certain other states are doing the
same thing they're getting rid of gas
stoves uh they're mandating electric
school buses military jets they they're
trying to get military jets to use
organic fuel way more
expensive we've had bills in this
chamber to Outlaw wood stes and on and
on but does hysterical climate activism
yield good public policy that's what
we're all about is laws public policy
will carbon
taxes on granite Staters stop climate
change will carbon taxes on us stop
climate change activists often cite
scientific consensus that's the point of
this measure uh not every voice is being
listened to or heard to many scientists
are being bullied the American
Meteorological Society did a member
survey and received
1862 responses only 52% of those felt
that 20th
century uh Global emissions had anything
to do with with global warming that's a
far cry from the 97% figure we keep
hearing in terms of scientists who
supposedly blame humans for clim climate
change so this brings us to the purpose
of this resolution which simply states
which simply calls for all voices to be
be heard as we develop climate policies
in this body and elsewhere experts who
are being threatened and ignored deserve
to be heard and we need to stop scaring
the heck out of our kids the way that
they scared the heck out of me at UNH
when I was a freshman
there most agree that measured most of
us agree that measured insensible
reductions in fossil fuel Em missals are
are desirable and we can do that by
working
together the EPA was established under
Republican Administration and together
together we've cleaned our lakes and
rivers we've cleaned our air I if you
remember how bad it was in New York City
or La we've worked together to fix or to
ameliorate that stuff for decades but
climate scientists who shut down debate
and try to impose radical measures
promote bad policies we're under in
incredible pressure schools are under
pressure to start teaching
climate is part of uh schools is a h sh
30 coming up from another committee so
anyway this regul this resolution simply
calls for us to listen to All voices and
if that seems reasonable and by the way
there was no if you notice in the
calendar there was no contrary Minority
Report uh who wants to step up and say
not to listen to All
voices so if you want to listen to All
voices as we put together policy then I
asked you to hit the green the Celtic
screen the uh St Patrick's Day Green
Speaker for what reason is a member rise
for a motion State your motion uh I
motion to table HR
27 order motion is in order the motion
before us is the table HR
27 a division has been called members
seats
sentive H has requested a roll call is
seconded it is not it is not
sufficiently
seconded
for what reason does the member rise the
question of the speaker question answer
State your question when I asked for the
roll call and you requested a second I
thought I saw more than 10 votes can we
I did not count 10 votes in their seat
and they had to be in their seats and
they it took maybe two minutes for
everybody to stand up when we ask for a
second everybody has to stand up right
away not look around the room to see who
has stand who is standing who
isn't Mr
Speaker is there a provision to allow me
to ask for a second roll call vote so we
can actually see if there's a
vote the motion the motion before us is
to table HR
27 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
McKenzie while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
187 voting a 185 voting a HR 27 is L on
the
table majority committee on state and
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred hcr9 in act
sending the application to the Congress
of the un States of America to call a
convention pursuant to the terms of
Article 5 of the United States
Constitution consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen of Tom Manion for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment pres of Christine
committee
maet you making a
motion repres recogniz representative
Granger to speak chair recognizes
representative
Granger uh thank you Mr Mr Speaker uh so
hcr9 resins an application for an
article 5 Constitutional
Convention you've probably heard from
people claiming that an article 5
convention experts from experts uh that
an article 5 convention is a well
understood process and that it can be
issue specific um I want to try to
convince people in uh in in my view that
uh this this is not the case okay so I
want you guys to do me a favor and if
you can go on your cellular telephones
just read article 5 of the US
Constitution I'm not going to wait for
you um but I have a couple questions for
you and you don't actually have to
answer this rhetorical but how are how
are the delegates selected and how many
delegates does each state get uh the
answer is it's not defined in Article 5
it's determined by Congress Congress
determines how the delegates are
selected they could simply choose that
they themselves are the
delegates uh that's well within their
power
do you want whoever is currently in
office to be the delegate to a
constitutional convention just think
about it uh question two does it mention
anything about an issue specific
Constitutional Convention so for
instance a constitutional convention
about a specific issue for a instance to
balanced budget amendment or anything
like that the answer is no it does not
it there's no such concept it is a
fabrication it doesn't exist uh proof
towards that is that though the
applications themselves can be about a
specific subject there is a federal
house resolution that is in the works to
combine all the Constitutional
Convention applications into one this
includes obsolete Constitutional
Convention applications under Article 5
that have absolutely nothing to do with
our specific Article 5 convention
application all right so what that means
is there is an active attempt by
Congressman to start an article 5
Constitutional Convention this might not
have been information you had prior so
this is something to consider and it
might change your mind on the topic um
so question three how can anyone claim
that they can be confident about
anything that comes out of a convention
all right here here's a little thought
experiment for you are people wiser Now
versus 100 years ago are people wiser
Now versus 200 years ago if you think
that they're not wiser now than they
were back then then you should trust the
people who are around throughout the
entire history of the United States who
all issued an article 5 convention it
has never been done it's gotten close
and every single time it gets close the
resend the the applications keep getting
rescinded there's a reason for that all
right that now isn't the time to do it
the world is way too
polarized uh so you might be thinking
why don't we just not ratify it if the
Constitutional Convention comes out with
un bad so if a constitutional convention
happens and they come out with a
constitution or even just an amendment
that's bad why don't we just get not get
rid of it you know we can just vote it
down well this takes a little bit of
History the Articles of the
Confederation required unanimous
agreement among everybody who was in all
the uh various states in the in the
states at the time to change anything in
the Articles of Confederation so the
actual Constitution at the time required
unanimous agreement among all the
various States before any changes can be
made Rhode Island boycotted they said
they weren't going to go so what they uh
what the other states did was they just
independently ratified it and then they
just went with the new constitution the
current constitution while and then all
the other states that didn't ratify it
kept the Articles of the Confederation
and this forced all those states to sort
of adopt the new US
Constitution uh if you imagine that sort
of thing happening now where we have 50
different states imagine 50 different
states deciding in various ways that uh
we're going to keep the current
Constitution and then other ones saying
well we're going to take the new
constitution it's just not a very good
idea it'll just split up the whole Union
um
so wrapping up uh Constitutional
Convention is uncontrollable states have
no say you the legislatures have no say
in what goes on at the Constitutional
Convention uh the Supreme Court has
absolutely no jurisdiction over a
constitutional convention a
constitutional convention outranks a
supreme court because the Constitutional
Convention makes new Supreme Courts they
derive their Authority directly from the
people they are not bound by the
Constitution they make constitutions
that's what they do the delegates and
lobbyists get to say what will be in the
new Constitution and they can use
standard political tactics all the ones
that we all use uh to decide what will
end up in any proposed amendments that
are made please support hcr9 to resend
you
sideb
sorry thank you Mr Speaker today I Rise
Against The committee report of an
expedient to legislate on hcr9 this
resends HCR 40 passed in 2012 12 years
ago HCR 40 called for an article 5
convention today's hcr9 hearing would
cancel that request for an article 5
convention I am concerned about both the
premise behind the original 2012
resolution and the procedural
complexities surrounding an article 5
convention let me first address the
premise I disagree with the notion that
a convention should should convene to
enact an amendment mandating a balanced
federal budget such a mandate poses
significant economic risks and could
undermine programs like Social Security
and Medicare and more impacting millions
of Americans and tens and thousands of
granite Staters equally concerning are
the procedural uncertainties surrounding
an article 5 convention some of which
you just to must Congress call an
article 5 convention in 34 states
properly ask for one if called are the
limitations on scope binding on the
convention what constitutes a valid
application to to Congress and who is
the judge of that how long are
applications valid the list goes on and
on with unanswered questions the
complexities and uncertainties
surrounding an article 5 convention
demand thorough Examination for these
reasons and more this body should push
the red button on an expedient to
legislate so another motion can be made
thank you Mr
Manion thank you Mr Speaker hcr9 seeks
to resend our active application to an
article 5 Convention of States
specifically 2012's HCR 40 which was an
applic for a balanced budget amendment
to the United States
Constitution of all the reasons to call
a convention the ballooning
34.5 trillion debt should remain the top
of our list by resending our application
we are left begging for the US Congress
to take it upon themselves to be
fiscally prudent a task they have proven
year over-year they cannot perform
estimates place the budget increasing by
$1 trillion every 100 days the treasury
secretary when asked about funding for
Middle East conflicts stated we can
afford two Wars DC is disconnected from
reality the tool provided to us from by
the founders is the Article 5 convention
process we have co-equal authority with
Congress to amend the US Constitution
and in manners which the legislative
branch is unable or unwilling to make
the change it falls to the states to
force the change part two article 100 of
the New Hampshire Constitution provides
a similar mechanism where every 10 years
the people of the granite state are
given a ballot question on whether to
call a State Convention to amend our
state
constitution we have had five such
conventions so we are no stranger to
amending
conventions members of this body have
attended a mock Article 5 convention to
go over the rulemaking process and
drafting of amendment language not
dissimilar to how legislators uh
legislator across the country function
and it was a resounding success the
United States government is addicted to
borrowing don't resend our application
to the amendment process that can
correct the mess DC has caused vote
green to support the committee position
hcr9 the motion be Force majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl on
hcr9 are you ready for the question who
requests a roll call Rep Kella requests
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
vote
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of nxp to legislator
and HCR
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative marter for a
parliamentary
inquiry this right yes thank you Mr
chair uh or Mr Speaker sorry if I know a
constitutional convention in the days of
social media would be a disaster and if
I know I actually love the Constitution
and that I think changing
it through a con uh convention is a
dangerous proposition sorry I can't wear
my glasses and read at the same time if
I know that Congress decides who will be
the delegates in a
convention if I know that every time
America gets close to a con con States
wisely
resend if I know that through HCR 24 in
the US Congress uh they're trying to
combine all articles of an article 5
convention uh thus destroying the idea
that a constitutional convention will be
a single issue Affair if I know the
Constitutional Convention outranks the
Supreme Court would I not then press the
red button to oppose the I thank
you chair recognize from Sen Tom Manion
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
over 11,000 Amendments have been have
been proposed to the Constitution by
Congress alone and if I know that
article 5 of the United States
Constitution provides two mechanisms to
amend the Constitution one of which is
the convention of States process and if
I know resending our active application
for a balanced budget amendment leaves
us at the mercy of Congress to clean up
their own mess then I would press the
green button to support itl on
hcr9 the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislator in hcr9 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor your presid
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent
please
all members present had the opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 128 voting a 238 voting a in
expedient to motion let legislate fails
represent
Cy
for what purpose do a member rise move
pass uh State your
question thank you Mr Speaker question
of the speaker uh do the rules of the
body on the other side of
this new microphone do the rules on the
other side of this body allow for this
concurrent resolution to be taken up
without the suspension of the rules we
do
noted uh we're not we don't get into the
procedures representa willhelm moves
ought to
pass and the minority amendment is 0433
h i are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
room
49 CH recognize Mr the clerk thank you
Mr Speaker uh the amendment is on page
49 it is proposed by the minority of the
committee the report on hcr9 on page 23
says The Minority Report is ought to
pass that was transmitted incorrectly it
is ought to pass with amendment is the
minority recommendation the amendment
that you'll be voting on uh with this
division is is the amendment uh in the
49 the motion before us is on the
minority Amendment
0433 H are you ready for the question a
division this is a division vote to clar
that's right we division vote to clarify
the vote Voice
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you'll
press a red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent
wheeler
love
represent
all members present had the opportunity
vote 209 voting nay 161 voting nay the
amendment is adopted now we're on a to
pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those oppose
nayay the eyes have it and the UT to
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill 1244 act prohibiting smoking
and ecigarettes in Motor Vehicles when a
passenger is under 16 years of
age having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
s of Ted Gorski for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass the Daniel V for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
representative
ve thank you Mr Speaker hb1 1244 makes
it a violation to smoke or vape in a
motor vehicle when a pass under the age
of 16 is present we all know that
secondhand smoke presents a serious
health risk and the risk of secondhand
vaping can be just as serious children
exposed to secondhand smoke or vaping
share the same risks as the smokers
themselves including exposure to toxic
chemicals respiratory issues
cardiovascular problems and cancer these
risks can be magnified in children
because developing lungs and growing
bodies are far more likely to sustain
long-term damage potentially leading to
lifelong health
issues
the member will suspend the member has a
right to be
heard once again if you need to have a
conversation take it out into the Annie
room remember may
continue thank you smoking has been
banned in most indoor spaces for decades
because of the wellestablished risk of
secondhand smoke and many of the
chemicals contained in ecigarettes are
known to have serious health risks of
their own the effect of secondhand smoke
and Vapor in vehicles is Amplified even
more because of the confined space even
with the windows cracked and ventilation
on smoke and Vapor become much more
concentrated within a vehicle compared
to other indoor spaces making the act of
smoking when children are present that
much more
dangerous young children are often un
unable to advocate for themselves in
these conditions throughout my life I
have dealt with intense migraine
headaches one of the triggers for these
headaches is tobacco smoke when I was a
child my father would reflexively light
a cigarette as soon as he got in the car
despite my please not to
often causing me to have to deal with
the pain that would often
ensue to try to appease me he would
crack the window to try to vent the
smoke which tended to Simply push the
smoke into the back
seat conditions at home weren't weren't
much better but at least I could Retreat
to my room and Clos the door as a
passenger in a car I was
trapped we required children under the
age of 18 to wear seat belts and
vehicles so it should be just as
feasible to ban smoking in in vehicles
when children are
present as a secondary law HP 1244 does
not allow police to pull people over
just because an occupant is smoking but
it sends a message that we understand
the dangers involved with smoking in
closed spaces when children are present
and demonstrates that we truly care for
those who cannot stand up for themselves
please push the red button to defeat the
itl motion so that another another
motion may be made thank you Mr Speaker
and our request a division vote Jer
recognize represent
gski
thank you Mr
Speaker I stand in support of the
committee report of itl and HB
1244 majority was against this bill for
two main reasons first the concept of
the secondary
offense basically you can drive you
could drive your vehicle smoke a
cigarette with an 8-year-old in your
back seat as long as you weren't stopped
by by federal authorities so basically
the intention of this bill as was stated
in testimony was to protect the children
but basically how this bill is written
it does not do that because as I
mentioned you can smoke in the vehicle
with someone under 16 as long as you
follow the rules of the road you can do
it second of all this bill is a slippery
slope it's really a civil liberties
issue basically the state and the
government is saying what you can cannot
do in the privacy of your vehicle so I
ask what's next is it you can drink
coffee in your car not listen to your
radio based on these reasons I ask you
to support the motion of itl by pressing
the green button thank you Mr
Speaker Granger has requested a roll
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
[Music]
vote
e
the motion before us is in majority
committee report of Meed to legislate on
House Bill
order this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that second
hand smoke in a confined enclosed space
is hazardous and extremely unhealthy to
children and
infants and if I also know that
children's bodies are particularly
vulnerable when they're subjected to the
smoke inside of a vehicle would I now
for the sake of and the protection of
our children vote no please push the red
button thank you J recognize rski for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill which creates a
$100 secondary violation does not really
protect children and if I know that this
bill is a slippery slope to civil
liberties then would I press the green
button and tell big big brother to stay
out of the cars of New Hampshire
citizens house will be in
order the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislator and House Bill 1244 it's a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
e
while members president had an
opportunity to vote how will tend to
stay to the
vote 188 voting yay 171 voting nay the
adopted
committee on transportation to which was
referred House Bill 1329 FN en act
relative to creating special number
plates for fire departments considered
the same report the same with a
recommendation that bill ought to pass s
of Daniel V for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I IE
nay the eyes have it the committee
adopted
Jo the committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 1332 FN
act relative to prohibiting electric
vehicles from parking and parking
garages considered the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass Senator Thomas walshford
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved it as inexpedient to legislate
representative Katherine rmo for the
minority of the committee chair
rmo thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today in opposition to the
recommendation of ought to pass for HB
1332 this morning I think most of us
pulled into the legislative garage
entrance on store Street we waved to our
patient attendant who did not stop us to
ask what type of vehicle we were driving
we headed up the ramp to whichever
available spot we figured would be
easiest to exit the long end of this
long day maybe we say good morning to a
fellow Committee Member or a district
colleague maybe we wave to a legislator
from across the aisle as we climbed out
of our cars and our trucks large ones
small ones electric powered and gas
powered and a few Intrepid
motorcycles we piled our lunches and our
laptops and our coats and our calar into
our bags we made our way into rep's Hall
where we are trying our best to keep our
neighbors safe while still getting
government out of the way of people's
can unfortunately HB 1332 will not make
us safer and will instead put government
squarely in our way more than any
traffic in the store's garage could this
bill seeks to prohibit parking electric
vehicles in any parking garage in the
entire State this ban would not permit
individual business owners or
municipalities to decide whether to
allow a variety of vehicle parking it
does not even seek to prohibit charging
an EV but simply just parking
one out of approximately 12,000 EVS
currently in New Hampshire there have
been only two car fires neither of which
occurred in parking garages for Better
or For Worse all vehicles are heavier
now than they were in years past not
just EVs and banning EVS from parking
garages will not significantly impact
increased vehicle loads on
garages to the extent that there are
concerns about vehicle fires in garages
they relate to vehicle weights and ages
overall flammability of tires garage age
and access for firefighters and open air
and sprinkler systems in garages the
fire rate of electric vehicles is 61
times lower than that of gasoline
vehicles yet this bill singles out EVS
without any real data to support it the
only example cited in committee to
support this legislation referred to a
fire in New York City that resulted in
the partial collapse of a parking garage
dating from the 1920s the structural
issues with that garage have been noted
as early as
2003 the risks to parking garages are
not risks inherent or exclusive to EVS
again there are RIS instead risks uh
that are more appropriately addressed by
garage standards not a state prohibition
on local control and privately owned
facilities I like pulling into stores
garage and seeing all the different cars
and trucks sometimes it's fun to guess
who might drive which one based on their
model and bumper stickers and
legislative plates the idea that we as a
government body might tell any of us
that we can't drive our own vehicle into
our own parking garage or someone else's
doesn't feel right it doesn't feel like
the way we make decisions in New
Hampshire without data to back it up and
we do not have the data here to support
more unneeded
regulation so to protect our private
property rights from State intrusion so
that you may continue to rely on the
vehicle of your choice and in the
absence of demonstrated safety risk to
the contrary I ask you to push the red
button so that another motion may be
made thank you Mr Speaker and I request
a division vote CH recognize rson of
Mark
pro thank you Mr
Speaker fellow Representatives I'm a
three minute rule gu so if I stop going
over three minutes yell at
and an F150 Ford gas is
4,500 lb an electric one is 7,000 lb
plus so yes weight of an electric
vehicle is a whole lot more than the
heavier gas cars
now if they catch fire they burn between
2,800 de and 3,000 de a lot hotter than
a gas vehicle
talked about in a garage yeah there's
some holes in there that allow venting
but nowhere near what it needs to be
when these vehicles off gas they off gas
carbon dioxide hydrogen methane organic
compounds ethane and other
hydrocarbons the batteries have a
tendency to
detonate
explode and if they don't explode they
we used to take 1,000 gallons Max to put
out a car fire now takes 30 to
40,000 gallons to put out a car an
electric car fire because they tend to
keep burning you put them out they light
again so trying to get that car out of
the garage is going to be an issue as
well because it'll probably light back
up as we're trying to get it out on the
tow
truck they talk
about there's only two car electric cars
reported burning in the state I know of
three offand because the reporting
system hasn't caught up to the
technology there is no checkbox for an
electric vehicle it's just a carfire
unless you go and read the narrative
that they wrote which is hard to capture
just with a search
so yes this is about safety it's about
firefighter safety it's about public
safety and
yes would you park a whole bunch of
electric cars in our
garage I'm pretty sure I wouldn't
because that would be the second garage
that collapses due to EVS so it has
happened it will happen again because a
lot of parking garages aren't what they
used to be right just like us so
I hope you vote for this for safety I
know I
know it's not visitor friendly but we're
trying to save their lives so please
push the green button thank you
represent Granger has requested a roll
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the motion before us is autop pass
majority committee report of autopass on
HB
1332 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Sullivan for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that business owners are
better than the government at deciding
how to run their business and manage the
risks to their property
and if I know Mr Speaker that growing
the business and telling a business
owner or a property owner how they
should or should not manage the risks
associated with that when we know that
the free market does a pretty good job
of doing that between working with their
insurance companies and working with the
other Market forces in in the respective
town and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the majority of people on this side
of the aisle and many of the people on
this side of the aisle all profess to
claim that the free market does a
prettyy good job of solving these sorts
of problems then would I vote no against
against this recommendation uh yes press
red and allow allow us not to expand the
nanny State of New Hampshire thank
you chair recognizes Representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
weight of a battery pack in a Hummer
electric vehicle weighs more than an
entire Chevy
sedan and that the increased weight has
compromised more than one parking garage
but specifically one in New York City
leading to the death of one person in
injuring five and Mr Speaker if I know
because a burning electric vehicle will
have to be removed from a parking garage
while it's on fire and M and most tow
trucks cannot fit into the garages to
get them out and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that in the 27 years I have been in
the fire service little has concerned me
greater than dealing with the complexity
of burning electric vehicles please vote
to pass
this the motion before us majority
committee report of autop pass on House
Bill 1332 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
e
[Music]
repr
wheeler all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 145 voting a 221 voting
a the motion
fails moves
representative rbo moves in expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those oppose
members need to take your seats we're
going to be going right into a another
vote majority of committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill
1403 an act relative to Temporary
vehicle emission control equipment
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment send John cellers for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate s
committee the amendment is
0612 printed in house record 10 page 48
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is I to
pass with Amendment this division has
been requested take seats members need
to take your seats this is going to be a
division
vote
the motion be for us is a majority
committee report of Auto passes amended
on House Bill 1403 this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we're talking
about a procedure that could take only
10 minutes to to happen all it is is an
OBD2 scanner hooked up to your car and
reset your light after it goes out and
if I
know that this is just extending a grace
period from 60 to 120 days but the the
present RSA allows you to apply for a
one-year
exemption and if I know if this passes
it will take at least 16 months to get
it approved from the
EPA and if I know applying to the EP PA
for this change can change
enforcement requirements including
roadside testing and Laser testing which
right now we are grandfathered out of
with our present situation and lastly if
I know that our own Department of
Environmental Services the experts we
rely on for expertise on the
environment to protect us is Viet
opposed to this wouldn't I press the red
button and move
on chair recognize represent of Gorski
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill helps New
Hampshire car owners who receive OBD
codes to help them fix problems to give
them from 60 to 120 days to fix their
problem and if I know these types of
issues can be quite costly and finally
and if I know the de Department of
Environmental Services came to our te
came in testimony with no position on
this bill would I then press the green
button to provide New Hampshire car
owners more time to fix these
complicated issues the motion before us
a majority committee report of aut pass
is amended on House Bill 1403 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you press the red button V voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 200 voting y66 voting a the
adopted
committee on ways and means to which was
referred CAC R15 relative to taxation
providing that a 2third vote is required
to pass legislation imposing new or
increased taxes or license fees or to
authorize the Assurance of State bonds
providing that the general court shall
appropriate funds for payment of
interest and installments of principle
with all state bonds came without
recommendation sen early is moving ought
to pass
Aly thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker cacr 15 may be the most fiscally
respon irresponsible bill ever to come
before this
legislature it would take only a third
of the legislature to kill any new taxes
increased taxes newer increased
professional fees and new bonding this
is likely to require that the capital
budget passed by a 2/3 majority and that
no increase for inflation ever again
incur in the fees that pay for our many
fee based
programs if any inflation required
increase was proposed in the operating
budget for our excise taxes or for a
need driven increase in some tax rate
the operating would also require 2/3 to
pass in both bodies although my
colleague for HUD from Hudson says we
would all ra rally in emergencies the
record in
1999 which was our greatest fiscal
challenge to date on the establishment
of the education trust fund belies this
Republicans as they had for 150 years
controlled both House and Senate in
finance we had cut the cost of
inadequate education as much as we could
without facing Court challenge but the
final cost was equal to 80% of our
existing annual budget operating budget
think about that we had to raise our
revenues 80% in one
year HB 117
inserted a Statewide property tax at 660
per th000 of equalized property value
but we still had to raise 2third of the
amount from new and increased business
and excise
taxes did we rally around the flag for
this
emergency there were 10 roll calls
during the three sessions and two months
that we fought about this bill the
highest yay vote was
57% to agree with the final Committee of
conference before that the best votes
were at
53% including one to table the bill
after the finance committee version went
down to ignominious defeat with
45% the new amended bill that became the
53% how are we ever going to vote by
66.7% in future emergencies to vote
together under this bill a one-third
minority could stop new bonding bonding
for reauthorizations of transportation
and other Capital items already approved
the treasurer's reissue of bonds to
achieve lower costs would be seriously
impeded and her Department action slowed
by the need to submit all Bond payments
by a simple 51% majority vote in the
House and
Senate the bill allows a small minority
to stop the issuance of funds for any
new professions Li license fees and for
the inflation D driven increases needed
for existing license fees as no more
Federal stimulus money is coming in
inflation is still simmering and the
revenues are beginning to decline it
stops any future Revenue adjustments
that would be required to maintain
existing services in this state State
the small minority could also deny
payment for lawsuits against the state
both those already won and those pending
which trigger would trigger a
constitutional
crisis ruled by a minority on all
matters of money is neither a republic
nor a democracy it is
chaos thank
represent
getting
old thank you Mr Speaker the proponents
of cic cr15 are profoundly aware of the
impact of taxes and
fees have on our neighbors we realize
that the quality of life in New
Hampshire is directly affected by the
disposable income and the ability to
enjoy one's life and property proper
cacr 15 seeks to give back to the people
the power that is inherently theirs that
is the power to fund government when
this province began Farmers Foresters
fishermen Merchants banded together and
decided that the
public under shared efforts were needed
to survive as a matter of fact that's
part of our initial oath or motto you
can see over on the left there be it a
Garrison Farm a stockade Fort or a ship
building port or even Mast Road the
expense was agreed on and shared by all
the decision was not foisted upon all by
a minority of one or two as is the
current situation rather the majority of
the taxpayers worked together somewhere
along the path of comedy with the
majority the slimmest of majorities
began issuing dictate as to how
government was going to take both money
from our neighbors and who amongst our
neighbors was going to benefit from that
taking these decisions cannot be made
lightly and should not be made on a
personal or partisan basis the
proponents recognize that taking money
from our neighbors is a serious matter
deserving serious consideration and in a
high degree of agreement as to the
purpose and the use of the funds
literally taken from our neighbors
Pockets because taxation without a large
degree of equinity and consensus and
collaboration results in bitterness and
divisiveness the largest possible
majority of those responsible for taking
our neighbors wealth must take place for
that reason if for none of the many
others
we being responsible to the people must
offer the ability to openly discuss this
amendment and let them to decide it into
include it into our
constitution we owe it to our neighbors
to move
this to the ballot thank you Mr
Speaker representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that's
officially
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the motion before us
is aut to pass on CAC R15 this is a roll
call vote chair recognize represent of V
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
current tax system in New Hampshire
gives huge tax breaks to the ultra
wealthy and large out ofate
corporations while hardworking Granite
Staters and our small businesses pick up
the tab and if I know that this
Constitutional Amendment would make it
harder to support those same hard
working Granite Staters and small
businesses with strong Public Safety
great schools and infrastructure that
drives our economy forward and if I
further know that this Constitutional
Amendment would hold hostage important
legislative functions such as the leg
such as the state budget and
transportation bonds to a minority of
the legislature resulting in gridlock
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
simple majority rule not super majority
rule whether you like a policy or not is
a fundamental principle of our
representative democracy then would I
now push the red button thank you Mr
Speaker CH recognize representative Jian
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that my constituents are
concerned about the high cost of paying
a multitude of taxes and fees and they
want to keep as much of their
hard-earned money as they can and if I
know that a super majority rather rather
than a simple majority is the best way
to limit new and increased taxes and
fees then would I press the green button
to pass the
cacr motion before us is a to pass in
cicr 15 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposer press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote houseen the state of the
vote 183 voting yay 185 voting a it
F committee on ways and means to which
was referred house bill this is going to
write into a division vote so if you'll
stay in your seats it'll be a lot
quicker
committee on ways and means to which was
referred House Bill 1554 a 1054a
relative to northern border Alliance
program fund comes without
recommendation sen fellow's moves ought
seats the chair recognizes
representative roachford for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
merely changes a non-aps fund to a
lapsing fund and this fund was just
established with a bipartisan Voice vote
less than a year ago if I know the rules
affiliated with this funds program were
just adopted in
November and if I know that the program
just began in Earnest in December and
this fund is used for such expenditures
as overtime and petrol s and if I know
that just yesterday I was speaking to
law enforcement in Coos County and they
are planning hundreds of patrols using
this money for the next couple of
months and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that it's just too soon to determine if
this bill is
needed and and an OTP on this is is
premature then would I now hit the red
button so another motion can be
considered Ed J recogniz representative
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know the
Northern Pass Program is a one-time
project funded by an appropriation from
Surplus made on the last day of the last
bium and if I know that in
hb2 this fund was designated non-aps
because that that is how we move money
from Surplus into the next biennium and
if I know that regardless of lapsing or
non-lps status this project will
continue be beyond June 30th
2025 only if the new governor and
legislature include it in the next
budget and finally if I know that
lapsing this fund on on June of 2025
will make its unspent money available to
fund urgent one-time projects for the
next bium and we always have plenty of
those when we get to the end of the bium
would I push the green button to pass
this
bill the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1054 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppos you
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
all members present an opportunity to
vote how forend to state of the
vote 188 voting aay 180 voting nay got
adopted committee on ways and means to
which was referred
House Bill 1254 local relative to
optional local public safety assessments
on certain room occupancies pres of all
be moves ought to
pass in offers Amendment
0681 printed in house record 10 page 45
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say i iose
n guys have it and the amendment is
adopted the chair
recognizes represent
ative for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
postpone hb1
1254 it is a proper motion the motion
is the motion is indefinite postponement
1254 Senate Sweeney has requested a roll
call was that sufficent is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
postponement
yet the motion before is inde Def
postponement on House Bill
1254 this is going to be a a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that many communities
experience a surge of visitors each day
due to various reasons such as tourism
retail restaurants sports activities and
more and if I know that this bill while
well-intentioned
primarily helps communities with
multiple lodging facilities but does not
help those communities adjacent to those
communities with lodging facilities and
it also fails to help those communities
that have many restaurants or retail
outlets and thus have increased costs
for police and Emergency Services then
would I press the green button to
support the motion of indefinite
postponement chair recognize represent
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that
many um there are many towns and cities
that are l a lot larger than their
neighbors that provide
services of many kinds to their
neighbors and provide jobs to their
neighbors and provide shopping to their
neighbors and um and there are also
tourism centers that
uh all end up with many more people who
are not taxpayers for the
municipality on
using their roads their fire their
EMTs uh their
police uh forcing us to increase the
size of all of those departments and pay
for them on the property tax of our town
and if I know that this bill was
constructed specifically to make sure it
did not harm in any way our neighbors
who are smaller and are coming into our
communities but is a very minor $2 at
the maximum increase on hotel rooms that
would be designed by the community with
the hotels and and voted on by the
community Community uh as to whether
they wanted to do this put the money
into a special fund to help with fire
police and
EMTs and Roads possibly on then would I
vote no I press the red button and vote
no on this motion of of um of inde
definite postponement thank you very
much bye the motion before us in dep
postponement on House Bill 1254 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house attend to say to the
vote 195 voting aay 171 voting nay hb1
postponed for what reason does a member
rise I move to print the remarks of HR
objection what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker given that we've already had
speeches on HR 27 I'd like to remove it
table
the question the question before
to the motion before us to move HR 27
from the table are you ready for the
question division has been requested
division has been
requested members take your seats this
vote
the motion be for us to move HR 27 from
the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposer press the red
seconds
[Music]
to all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 170 voting a 195 voting a the
motion
fails for what reason does the member
rise to make a
motion having voted on the in side I
move reconsideration on HB 1054 and urge
no the motion before us
is reconsideration on House Bill 1054
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested all
seats
the motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill 1054
this say division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity
vote house will tend to stay the
motion
members stay in your seats we've got a
quick vote coming up we have two bills
with no de just divisions and piis the
next two bills which are our final two
bills are divisions with just piis so if
everybody will stay in your seat we'll
get done pretty quickly the majority
committee on ways and means to which was
referred House Bill 11 1391 FN the ACT
allowing new vehicle purchased in the
model year or before to be inspected in
the second year after the purchase
consider the same report the same of the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senator Walter spillsbury for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Richard
ases from a minority of the committee
this is going to be a division
seats
for
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass and House
Bill 1391 this is a division vote chair
recogniz the representative Ames for
parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill
1391 will eliminate mandatory vehicle
inspections for periods of up to 30
months after the date of purchase of a
new vehicle regardless of the distance
traveled by or the wear and tear
experienced by the vehicle during that
pre-inspection
time and if I know that many such
uninspected Vehicles will have been
driven as much as 70,000 Mi before the
date of the first required
inspection and if I know that tires
brakes steering mechanisms and exhaust
control devices may all fail during this
extended period of pre-inspection time
but that that but that this bill
includes no fee supported system nor
fiscal analysis of measures that would
at least provide for placement on these
vehicles of stickers to enable and pay
for identification by Public Safety
officials of the pre-inspection status
and potential public safety issues
presented by these
vehicles and if I know that data reports
showing low levels of new vehicle
current law inspection failures are
misleading because life safety issues
discovered during inspection are often
corrected prior to completion of the
inspection process knowing all of this
wouldn't I now press the red button to
oppose the pending OTP motion thank you
Mr Speaker jerich and I spillsbury for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
deferring inspection of vehicles
purchased new in the model year or
before until the second year after
purchase would reduce annual inspections
by approximately
83,000 and save owners over $3.3 million
per year plus their time and their
effort and if I know that passing this
bill would not substantially compromise
Public Safety given that just onethird
of 1% of the
78,2 first year in inspections conducted
in
2023 resulted in Failure mostly for
minor issues classified as vehicle info
glass or tires and if I know further
that we do not charge inspection fees
for the purpose of generating state
revenue and that this bill would have no
material fiscal impact on the state with
any loss of fee based Revenue trivial in
comparison to car owner savings when I
now press the green button and cast a
common sense TP
vote the question before us is the
majority committee report of water to
pass the amendment on House Bill 1391
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
represent
BL
all members present had opportunity to
vote 219 voting yay 145 voting aay Comm
report is
adopted
last majority of the committee on ways
and means we're on the last bill ladies
and gentlemen last bill you stay in your
seats it'll be a lot
quicker majority committee Ways and
Means to which was referred House Bill
1536 FN an act relative to increasing
the amount of the expense deduction
allowed against business profits tax
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass seal yours for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved as
inexpedient to legislate representative
Susan Aly for the minority of the
committee a division has been requested
e
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autop pass on House
Bill 1536 this is a division vote the
chair recognizes representative Susan
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker this state has never kept up
with the everchanging vicisitudes
of can you not hear
it oh if I know sorry that this state
has never kept up with the everchanging
vicissitudes of the congress's federal
expense deduction in
2011 uh we were arguing about whether to
follow them up to to
$100 and someone and if oh yes okay
um
yes if I know that we have never kept up
with the federal exemption but that the
federal exemption sometimes goes up and
sometimes goes down
um and that in 2025 and Beyond the
member remember must be in their seat
and if I know that forgoing more Revenue
than we will need next year and Beyond
may be harmful to our younger
generations and others in need of
Greater educational mental health and
job supports than we will be able to
afford uh and that this
makes a and if I know that this will
cost us money on would I
vote no red thank you chair recognizes
in thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill allows for assets
put in service as of January 1st 2025 to
be expensed up to 1 million from the
current limit of 500,000 and if I know
that this 1 million amount is more in
line with current IRS limits
and if I further know that this helps
stimulate businesses to invest and stay
competitive and finally if I know that a
bipartisan majority recommended passage
of this bill in the Ways and Means
Committee
16-4 would I now press the green button
to support the OTP
motion the mo the motion before us is
the majority committee report of autop
pass and House Bill 1536 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
y house the house will be in order we're
almost done
here all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
say to the
vote 272 voting y 89 voting aay the
committer report is adopted now if
everybody will stay in their seats for
just a minute we have a couple of
consents the chair recognizes a member
from Auburn representative osbor for the
third reading motion you Mr Speaker
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only that all bills ordered a
third reading be read a third time by
this resolution that all titles of bills
be the same as adopted and that they be
passed at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet
Thursday March 21st at 10:00
a.m. questions on the third reading
motion are you ready forther question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognize representative
announcement thank you Mr Speaker um
anyone who's interested in Housing
Solutions to our housing crisis
um the mercus center from George Mason
University members of the mercus center
are coming up to New Hampshire tomorrow
to speak with legislators who are
interested in Housing Solutions it may
surprise you since the mercada center
from George Mason University tends to
lean right and is um a pro- free market
approach to Solutions it may surprise
you that I have worked quite closely
with them and they've been incredibly
help helpful with uh information on
housing issues and so I would like to
personally invite especially members on
committees that deal with housing issues
like municipal or Judiciary but anyone
who's interested in housing issues to
please come uh we plan on having an
informal get together after the housing
committee tomorrow should be around
10:30ish at room 302 in the L they are
also holding an official workshop at the
marac courthouse on Court Street at 3:30
with housing Advocates homelessness
issue Advocates Realtors and Builders so
really the whole span of everyone who's
interested in housing issues are being
brought together that by the mercades
center they have lots of good data on
what's going on and lots of we may not
agree on all solutions but they've been
incredibly helpful with their data so I
welcome anyone interested to come
broody
oh thank you Mr Speaker all members and
staff are welcome on
Tuesday uh Wednesday March 20th 2024 in
room 104 for the annual acupuncture day
um to see what acupuncture can do for
you reless or whatever um if you're
curious at all or if you just want a
free treatment come on over they're
there all day thank you chair recognize
for the clerk thank you Mr Speaker uh we
have this coming weekend the YMCA Youth
and government program will be utilizing
our committee rooms and chamber so
please make sure your seat pockets are
empty you don't you have not left any
trash in your seat or nearby your seat
uh please help us help the youth that
will hopefully someday replace us thank
you Mr Speaker representative officer
mov the house standing recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills and
rooll build amendments rooll Bill
reports vacate motions receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos n
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house is in recess until
a.m.
e